Ah, oh my gosh, wait.
I'm still buffering.
Give me a sec.
I forgot to open the most important thing.
There we go.
Hello, everyone.
Hello, hello.
Uh, Sturm, oh, thank you for the Aka soup.
Bye, thank you.
Thank you.
Good job.
Clean your room, Doki.
I'm proud of you.
I didn't finish cleaning it.
But I, okay, so speaking of cleaning my room, um, I left like one.
I, I, okay, so before I left, um, I might have accidentally left like, um, like two plates of, like two bowls from my pre-cooked meals.
And I didn't realize the lid wasn't closed.
Um, because like I didn't finish it.
So, and then when I came back, I was, like putting all the dishes like i was putting the pre-cooked bowls um because they gave us like glass containers so i had to clean it and everything and then um i was putting them in the dishwasher because i was like oh shit okay i need to clean this um like i came back and then and then i and then i like looked at the bowl and it was just mold it was just all mold i was like like i jumped scared myself
i was like oh no it's last of us it's it's really a bowl of I had to like jump scared me.
I was not expecting it I was just like, oh shit Yeah, I'm infected No, I have to clean it because it's glass bowl and like I have to clean it because like it's not mine.
It's from the chef.
So So I
Yeah, so I didn't put that specific bowl yet into the dishwasher because it's literally a bowl of mold.
So I have, I think I have to like scrape it out.
Do I scrape it out before I put it?
It's a lot.
It was, I, it scared me.
Yeah, I have to scrape it out and then put in the dishwasher.
Yeah.
I don't know what to do.
because I have to I don't know where they bought it
um like I have to throw throw like I have to like they'll charge me a lot if I don't give back all the balls yeah so um yeah so that scared me a lie is it okay if i'm breathing it because like i didn't notice it until today um because obviously i came back yesterday and i went to bed and i'm thinking oh my god i slept i i slept with that in my in my kitchen
My windows are open, though.
My windows are open.
It's okay.
I opened the windows when I, like, this morning.
Because I was like, hmm.
I think I have.
Why are you like this?
It's okay.
Not good, but okay.
Will I?
Oh, do me.
Thank you for the rain.
Okay.
They don't know.
Guys, they don't.
They don't have to know, guys.
They don't have to know, chat.
Okay, but how long is long-term?
That's the thing.
How long is long-term?
Because I...
Anyway, hello, everyone.
Hello, everyone.
Doobie from DoobieStream.
I was watching a little bit of Doobie doing her little karaoke.
I got a little sneak peek of her 2D when we were both in New York City.
But yes, for those who don't know, I was gone for...
My business trip was basically me going to...
Me and Doobie going to New York City for Comic-Con.
Because Capcom invited me to check out their newest games, the newest Resident Evil, and also Onimusha.
Or Onimushu?
Oh my gosh, I keep...
I don't know which one.
I keep saying... Onimusha.
I like to say Onimushu, but it's Onimusha.
I mean, they had other ones.
Do they have the Monster Hunter one?
Because we get to choose, like, which games we wanted to play test, I guess.
I think it was, like, we wanted to check out.
So, there was, like, the Monster Hunter...
The newest Monster Hunter game.
There was the Pragmata.
And then there was...
you know, obviously you wanted to try out Resident Evil, and for me, it would be Onimusha, so we went and checked those out, but yeah, huge shout out to Capcom for inviting me and for letting me bring, for letting me bring Duby along with me, because I was like,
um, because, you know, I was just like, oh, uh, can I get a plus one?
Yeah, bring a plus one.
They're like, yes, yeah, we can, because like, all the tickets were sold out, too, at that time.
Um, all the tickets were sold out, so I thought figured, like, you know, it would be a great experience.
Duby and I were talking before, and stuff like that um and her aunt was also like a huge fan of musicals as well um and i was like you know what yeah you want to come to new york with me and then you know i had an extra i had an extra plus one ticket and then um but it was a great time um so yeah huge shout out to capcon uh 4d invitation that was basically my business trip um um i just stayed in new york a little longer because i was like you know i'm in new york city um great way to waste money i guess
been in new york city in a very long time the last time i was in new york city was i think like um nine years ago i think um so it's been um uh you know it was fun coming back after so long and i wanted to like you know experience like you know have a cool experience like um just going around new york city like the food and stuff like little italy um i went i did go to chinatown i did i I went to little Italy.
I didn't buy a lot of stuff.
Oh, I will say there was one.
I did spend a lot of money on one thing.
God, my God.
I didn't spend a lot of money this trip because like when, for those who didn't know, I used to go to New York a lot, like nine years ago.
I went to, back then, I went there like, I think it was, I don't even know if it's not.
I don't know maybe eight years ago um but um back then you know when I'm you know go to Nintendo store I go to Rockefeller you know back then I spent a lot of money back then when I was in New York at that time um but like this time it was more about like the experience I spent a lot of money on the experience of New York City um so I went and saw lots of museums a lot of like activities to do food as well I didn't buy a lot of stuff because like even when I was in Nintendo World not even buy anything in the Nintendo store.
I almost did.
I almost bought something in the Nintendo store.
But then I was like, I don't really, I don't know.
I think like the older you get, the less material things you buy, other than my own merch.
Um, that's the only thing I, I think like, for me, I, I spent money on my own merch.
That's it.
On my own, not my, on my own stuff.
Like, and like at artist alley too.
I would spend money on me, but I won't buy like, I haven't been buying other things like I didn't even buy stuff at Nintendo Store because I was just like do I really need it I don't really have space anymore because I just have space for my merch I was like thinking oh man do I really need it like do I don't even have space for this I only have space for like my own stuff like my for dokey merch not for like I was like there was a giant there was like a there was like a giant Pokemon plush um where it's like there's mochi plush of like pipelup and uh slowpoke and I was like oh it's so cute I was like I was debating for so long I looked at that shelf for so I'll show you guys what it looks like I looked at that shelf for so long like because I'm like do I buy it oh I was just like staring at it for like I think like 15 minutes like like debating in my head like do I buy it and bring it home oh man but I'm thinking I don't have room.
I just don't have room in my apartment.
That's the only thing holding me back.
I was like, I just don't have space for it.
Like 90% of the space in my room is just ducky merch.
That's it.
But I debated for so long.
Oh, wait, where's the image for this?
I'll show you guys.
this i you guys have no idea i i i i was i stared at this for 15 plus minutes being like oh do i get it
hey guys they give the five give the chips they can thank you burn out they give the 10 give the chips they can thank you oh my gosh i almost did i almost did this is just not i just had no room There was just no room in my apartment.
I...
It was so soft, too.
It was so soft.
I didn't.
I didn't get it.
Laughing.
Thank you.
Toki, infinite money glitch.
Buy your merch.
Restock it for free.
Buy merch again.
Restock for free.
You get so much profit.
Bye, Toki merch.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Wait, what was I...
What was I talking before?
Before I talked about...
What was I on about before I was talking about the, oh yeah, yeah, sorry, the one thing I, okay, do not judge me, okay, you're gonna judge me, okay, I think I deserve to be judged, but, but, um, at Comic-Con, they had a Swahski booth, okay, okay, bear with me,
stay with me, guys, stay with me, guys.
with me there was there was a swahski booth and at that booth they had several like different collaborations um at the swahski booth and there there are two collabs that was very interested in and do we also almost bought one i i was gonna um you was also gonna almost bought one but not the one I bought,
not the collab I bought.
So, Duby saw the Minecraft collab from the Soasky booth.
like, it was so cool.
Okay, there was like the creeper and the pig.
She almost, she almost got the creeper and, because I was like, you should do it.
You should get, because I bought something, but it wasn't the Minecraft one.
I kept I was like the demon the devil on his shoulder I was like but you should get it bro you should totally get it so imagine just having it sit on your desk for dude like who would own a Sooski Minecraft like a Sooski creeper uh crystal like you should totally she's like but she's like oh I'll think about it like I'll I'll when we're back tomorrow maybe I'll get it Yeah,
I was just like, you should, it's so good.
Like, like, come on.
Who else?
Who else would own one?
And look how good, look how pretty that is.
Okay, anyway, so I didn't get the Minecraft one because there was something else that caught my eye.
And there's something else that caught my eye.
Whoa, wow, we are looking at it and Do not, you are all gonna judge, I know you're all gonna judge me, but you don't understand You're all, I know you're all, you don't understand, so I
So I God I I saw The minions collapse And I was like, I need to have it.
So, I bought the one with the one with the teddy.
I don't even know their names.
I just don't understand.
I saw this.
I was like, oh my God, if I'm going to have any Swarovski, I don't want to trade.
should be a minion.
So this was the, this was my, this is, this was my, your super chat went into.
And you don't understand, you don't understand, this is your brain on most sports.
That you have to stick with a super chat thing.
You don't understand, guys.
That's not Bob, It was so worth it.
This was my only expensive purchase.
I didn't buy anything else.
Okay, this was my one purchase that I made for myself.
At least I didn't buy a Funko Pop.
I bought this little guy right here.
Look at this.
I bought this little guy.
We'll crop the price out.
I bought him.
This was my purchase.
So this little guy, it's gonna, it's gonna sit on my desk and every time I see it, this is what my money goes to.
Thank you for the super chat rules.
Thank you, thank you.
R&D, thank you for the super chat.
This will surely appreciate and value.
So now I'm thinking of the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Yeah, we don't.
understand we were right we don't understand oh thank you for the super chat thank you thank you like look at it it's because to my desk and every time i look at it i'll remember uh i remember how how good a time how good time of a time i had a comic-con no i bought this guy i bought this little guy um i just i can't help i need like okay i was thinking like if i was gonna this was If I was going to own any Swahski thing,
it had to be minions.
Like, it just had to be.
I was like, because, like, I was like, why does it, first off, why does it have a Swahski collaboration?
And then I was like, this is a once-in-a-lifetime opportunity, you know?
It could become a collector's item.
You don't know that.
In 50 years, this would be like a sought-after item because they don't redo collabs, guys.
They don't read.
It's a limited edition.
Bob Sooski.
Crystal.
Sooski Crystal.
Limited edition figure.
It's gonna, it can only go up.
You don't understand.
The value of it can only go up.
What if crystals are some, what if we suddenly lose all crystals?
Like there's no more crystals on earth.
no more crystals on earth so waski has mined all the crystals and then this is like one of the like one of the hundreds of crystals left in the world and yes but this isn't made in a lab this was mined in hard earth
yeah you'll just take your way to through to the other side of the world eventually sliding even the super chat thank you thank you the super chat thinking thank you you know you put it on stream a few times you call it right up not cpa could sell your tax professional just say that you was super chat and it was cheaper and it was cheaper than the minecraft collab
i mean i think this was a worthwhile purchase i mean okay so if you guys don't follow me on twitter um it started very unlucky i mean there was some unlucky bits scattered throughout the trip but it started out very unlucky because i missed my flight
so um i missed my flight because i was three minutes late for baggage check-in um so i think That was a wake-up call.
That was a wake-up call for me.
I was like, I gotta get my shit together.
No, that was not what the tweet was about because it gets worse.
So, um, so that, that, when that happened, it was like a wake-up call.
And I was like, I really gotta get my shit together.
I should not, I, I was literally three minutes late, um, from the cutoff for, like, I just needed to like put my baggage like put my baggage through check-in so i couldn't check in because like obviously like um they closed the check-in already like uh like i could go in i already checked in like myself i needed like my bag to be checked in so like my plan was like what if i just leave my bag leave my suitcase at the airport and then like and i just go in and then i buy close in New York City.
I was that desperate because like it was literally the last flight um to New York City um on that day.
So I was trying to do that and then like I went like I went to like the baggage check it like the the like um storage area and they're like you gotta fill out a form and then and then and then I looked at the form and there was so much to fill in.
I was like I'm not gonna make it.
I was like, I'm not gonna make it because I still have to go through security.
Um, so, so, um, so because of that, I was just like, fuck, okay, I guess.
And then I looked, um, I, yeah, I was like, I'm not gonna make it.
There's no way I can fill up or I'm in time, and then go through security and then make it to the flight.
So, so like, I, I, I, I, I calculated And I was like, there's no way
So, I was like, why did I Got there too late?
I sort of like disassociated Because you know how I was like, I didn't sleep So, because I was like, I'm just gonna sleep on the plane You know, so I fucked up And I disassociated a little bit Too long So, um So, so that's why I was like, this was a wake-up call.
I gotta get my shit together.
So, um, so, like, because of that, I was like, oh, I looked at the time.
I was like, oh, fuck, I had to take, I had to take the Uber right now.
Yeah, so, that's why I missed the flight.
So, it was so bad.
Um, it was, it was so bad.
And, um, um, wait, I wrote everything down.
Give me a sec.
Let me, okay, so.
So, I had to stay at the airport for like six hours until like the sun came on.
That was, so I had to buy a new ticket.
Well, I didn't have to worry about the return trip.
It was just the going there ticket.
So, so I had to wait up in the airport for six, because I was not going to fucking go back home.
I was like, I'm here.
So I waited six hours.
six hours at the airport until the fucking sun came out and then I flew over and then I flew over to New York City so yeah, no, Duby was there first because she was like, where are you and I was like, about that I may or may not, I missed my play I was like,
I might be like I might arrive like 10 hours later So, um, so, uh, during, this is where it gets even more fucked up, during the middle of the flight, to all you women out there, you know that feeling where you're like, oh no,
to all the women out there.
So, in the middle of flight, I felt something, and I was like, oh no, but I was too scared to check.
I was just, I, because, okay, for those who are like, oh, why don't you track it, you know, like, you know, like all the other women do?
I can't because it's so, my period is so irregular.
for a very long time so like i never it's like always a surprise because i never know so i i never know so so in the middle of it i was just like oh no because i i was like there's no way but it happened it happened the conch you came and it was like a little surprise like a little middle of the flight um and also um no i was i after i got off the flight you know after i got off the flight and i was in the airport i was like diamonds gotta buy some pads so yeah um so yeah anyway uh it's a little gotcha surprise uh anyway so i had to sit in between by the way i also had to sit because the flight was apparently like um super packed and everything i sat in between an old couple and they were like to me we're like they're like yeah we're together we bought this we we made we try to buy like the seats between the middle seat hoping that no one would sit in the middle i was like oops sorry like they told me that I was just like,
I was like, oh, sorry, the flight is down.
This was the only seat left.
Like, I had to sit there between an old married couple.
I was like, oh, jokes on you guys.
Guess I'm here.
I'm just like, why would you, why would you bet on that?
Like, I, first off, I'm like, why would you like bet on the fact that no one will, the possibility that no one?
One's gonna abide in the middle seat like I'm sorry there's freaks out there in the world that will sit in the middle But like that's I'm not one of them though.
I know I had to get it because it was the last seat It was literally the last seat left and it was funny What's funny is that there were actually seats beside us That was like empty because they didn't show up.
I think they were like me where they missed the flight they they they didn't show up so the old lady before we took up was like oh hey um when we take up you can take that seat over there i was like yeah of course i can and then i fell asleep so i guess like i guess fucker again i'm so tired i had didn't sleep for like more than 20 for i was like don't worry i definitely will do that and then like before the plane took up i'm fucking passed out.
And then when I woke up, I woke up, I was like, it's too late.
I moved.
You know, when I woke up, I could feel it, you know, like the moon was shining.
And, and then I was like, I'm not getting up.
I'm sorry, ma'am.
I am not getting up.
I just stayed in my seat.
I was like, if I move, something will happen.
And I was not moving.
I, the moon calling for me um so so i was just like sorry i guess i'll be i guess i'm gonna stay in the middle
um um uh patria said thank you for the super chat thank you thank you i don't know a lot about that story but i do know that woman of note tends to keep some spares in the back yeah you know i would have done that if i wasn't running on if if like i didn't have my shit together Like,
you know, I, you know, like, um, it didn't help that I spent, like, 20 minutes trying to find, like, trying to figure out which plushie I was going to bring to New York City, too.
So, that didn't help as well.
Uh, yeah, I was not prepared in general.
So, I even brought, I accidentally brought shorts.
Like, because I was like, I don't know how cold New York City is.
It was like, like half of my, I had to buy more pants in New York City because I was just like, it could be hot.
Like I was sitting there, it's like, it could be, it could be hot.
And so I brought like half of the pants I brought were shorts or like to my knees.
And so I ran out of long pants during my, during my trip in New York.
Tokyo is like, I don't know.
I was like, how?
how bad I was like thinking like hmm global warming has been pretty fucked up I was like maybe it's not that cold and I was just like I was just like I was like hmm I don't know maybe global warming hit New York City hard check the temperature I was like so bro it's I told you this trip was a wake-up call for me.
I was like, I can't get my shit together.
So like, this trip was like the wake-up call for me to get my shit together, because I was a fucking mess.
I was a fucking mess.
Anyway.
So, also, I accidentally, when I was buying a ticket, the newer ticket, to fly to New York, I actually bought a ticket to New Jersey instead.
But thank God, thank God I have a membership card to air like an uh, like the aeroplane to air Canada so I can get a refund So at first the first flight I bought was to New Jersey and said because I was I because apparently New Jersey also has a because if you do like to New York it gives you this other airport That's located in New Jersey and not in JFK.
Um, so I was so confused Yeah, I, I, for some reason, I don't understand, um, because I guess it's close to New York City, so they're like, it works, you know, like, so I don't know, I wrote, I wrote to New York, and they gave me the first, the one, the closest flight,
because it was the earliest flight, was to New Jersey, so, so, yeah, I, it took me to the EWR airport, and then I was looking at it I was like EWR I'm supposed to go to JFK maybe it's another airport in New York and then I looked at and then you know I bought the ticket because I was panicking you know I was like panicking and I was like not okay like my mind was not okay at that time it still isn't but you know it's a lot better um and I was like boom and then after I paid I was like wait a minute why does this say like why does this say New Jersey
so I was like oh fuck I bought the wrong ticket thank god I have like I have a membership for Air Canada so like they fully refunded yeah I checked after I told you guys I wasn't okay I was not okay and I told you it was so bad it was so I make my own my own like apparently um rice thank you the super chat thank you thank you um it's because ewr is a much bigger international airport than either the ones in new york city so let's just use that as a nearby hub thank you the super chat thank you thank you so anyway i got that refunded and i bought the right one to new york city but anyway after i've arrived in the jfk airport um apparently like to my hotel it was supposed to be 30 minutes apparently um when i arrived the roads to the airport were blocked so because i was like we're all the taxis i was just so confused i was like where did all the taxis go like because i was there was a lie and then we were waiting i was like that's weird that that's that's like weird and i looked at
google maps I was like, what's going on?
And then there's been, apparently they closed down an important road that leads to the airport.
And it was closed for like two hours at that point.
So I was just like, oh my God.
Like, if I arrived at my actual time, I would not have had to go through this because they actually closed it two hours ago.
Let's just keep getting worse.
So, basically, I was in a line for a taxi.
But it wasn't even a super long line, too.
But there was literally no cars coming in.
So, I was in that line for, like, 20 to 30 minutes.
And then, I was in a taxi for an hour plus.
I like it.
I was just like, oh, because I was stuck in traffic for that fucking long because they closed the roads down.
Like, that is, that's, bro, you're this close to coming to Gotham City.
You would have loved to have you there.
Just so, guys, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Yeah, so I think, you know what's crazy?
My flight actually arrived.
hour early so I was like oh my god I get to be at the hotel like an hour early that was a lie that was it just it was there to compensate with me being stuck in traffic for an hour yeah it got evened out to an hour early too like jokes on me the roads closed so So it canceled each other out.
So yeah, so that's basically the start of like how unlucky I was.
By the way, I didn't start using the subway until like the second last day.
That's what I've been through.
So Google Maps have lied to me a lot of how long it takes me to go from one place to the other.
um because i'd be like oh it's just a 30 minute taxi ride it was not like every time i like go to like every time i went somewhere i was like oh it's just a 30 minute taxi ride it was not a 30 minute taxi ride it does not count because i looked i was like okay so there is there is this one block of thing on google maps that's blocked that has traffic jam but it still account it says it says this should be i was stuck at most at twice i twice uh where i was stuck in the taxi i didn't uber because uber was so expensive compared to like the taxis i learned that because i tried it out like i was like okay i'll uber first and then i'll do a taxi next an uber for like one time it cost me a hundred fucking dollar canadian monopoly money though by the way it's not a hundred money um to go to like i guess like the inner city of new york because i my my hotel was in around chinatown and i wanted to go to like the inner city of new york city and then i tried like that is that is fucked up i was
like that that's so fucked up so then i and then i took a and then i took a taxi um i took a taxi and it was like 20 so i was like i I was like, I'm not an Uber in here.
It was like 20 to 30 Monopoly money when I took a fucking taxi compared to an Uber.
Anyway, so the reason why but yeah, I wasn't one time I was stuck in traffic for an hour.
It was like two to three times.
I tried my luck two more times with taking a taxi.
And it was like, I was stuck in traffic for like an hour, like an hour twice after that like so you're like why didn't you take the subway why aren't you trying like what okay i had a fear i was i was scared that's why i was i was very scared um so the reason why i didn't take the subway is because i'm so used to asian subway asia subways and metros and subway in new york city um before like you know like eight plus years ago and and like it i remember the smell and like it was just scary like i and so then and then obviously my fear of the new york subway got worse because of the internet um so so i was just like i like i was like i was so like I was just so paranoid because remember guys remember that fucking one day a lady got burned alive in the fucking new york subway and no one did anything and then I thought I was like oh my god what if that was me I was like and then and then also like rat then there was like clips of like rant yeah there was a one time there was one time in
New York City a lady got burned it was that in Brooklyn I don't know I don't know it's just somewhere there like it was like slow it was like a PvP zone and like yeah and so like what I think a lot of people also got stabbed in the New York subway so like it it was in Konya it was close enough Konya Island is like next to New York like it's close enough like And then also,
also, also the fact that like, I would see clips of like, random people just going into the subway and just start singing and like performing.
And I don't fuck with that.
I don't fuck.
I was like, what if they get close to me?
Like, I don't, I don't fuck with that.
And also like clips of like crazy people in the subway doing crazy shit.
And I'm just like thinking like, my god like I don't want to I don't want to deal with that and the smell too like I swear to God like it just smells like pee like so so I I got like I was just like oh my god like it's like GTA down there um so there's like and then people are just so used and then like all the New Yorkers are just so used to it too so um i don't want to be part of this and um and like yeah it just yeah and it just smells fucking terrible so um it's like a fucking pvp zone so that's why i like avoided the subway for so long because i got really scared uh so i was willing to tank the traffic also like i got worried that it was gonna be super crowded because i don't know when exactly I really worried that um that was gonna be like super fucking crowded um and everything um so um so like I I was worried I didn't want to get robbed or pickpocketed too because of it so I don't know when rush hour is and like when it ends like so I did I did it once I did use the subway once
and that was because we were going to um a Broadway show And then like, we saw the map.
We saw like, oh, it says 30 minutes.
And there were two roadblocks.
There were two roadblocks on the Google Maps.
But it said 30 minutes.
Like not roadblocks, but it was red.
So it was like traffic jam.
So I was like, it says 30 minutes.
But I know in my heart, it was going to be one hour.
Because I already tested it out.
it was 30 minutes and I see two red blocks like two red blocks indicating a traffic jam I know it's an hour it's not 30 minutes so I was like we should take the subway like this is it it says subway is 20 minutes and I think the subway is more correct yeah yeah I was like pattern recognition I was like I know the subway will actually be 20 minutes and then I you know we had to go to the Broadway show um we didn't want to be late so we're like because I got worried like oh man I got worried that we'd be late so I learned but luckily when we did the subway um it wasn't rush hour because I don't know when rush hour starts and ends in New York City because I feel Like,
I feel like, you know, like it's like all over the place depending on like what you work at So it smelled like pee.
No, it still smelled like pee So luckily it was like, it wasn't even there were seats like there wasn't a lot.
It wasn't that busy To the point where we could actually sit down like thank fucking god and there were no like Random people performing and there was no one there that stabbed me like it just smells like pee At least, you know, I didn't have someone randomly stabbing me in the train.
Like, don't worry.
I brought hand sanitizer because I was like, like, if there was one time I need to use hand sanitizer, this will be it.
So I did bring hand sanitizer when I went into the subway.
Thank God That's the scent of Mark territory Patria said thank you for super chat Okay okay so By the way Doobie unlocked a new Fear of mine for me For the subway because I was like We're gonna take the subway And then okay I wrote this down Because I can't believe she said this to me I She She was like,
oh, yeah, by the way, Doki, don't stand too close to the edge.
People have been known to push others onto the track.
And I was like, what the fuck?
Excuse me.
She's like, yeah, apparently I read that in New York City.
Yeah, like, yeah, like people would just push people onto the tracks if you stand too close.
And I'm like, what the fuck?
just like what this is actually a pvp zone like like the subway is the new york city is actually p is actually a pvp zone so it unlocked by the way we were about we're heading towards the subway when like when she told us me that so i was just like excuse me like mind the gap i was just like
pvp is always on yeah this i get i guess good thing i know i good thing i know oh the hell um um uh please thank you for the super chat thank you thank you just gotta pretend you're oh she visited us some way first um uh uh miki thank you the super chat thank you thank you sometimes Intrusive thoughts and do win.
Thank you.
It was super chat.
Ash, welcome to the tomato farm.
Welcome.
Um, but yeah, no, I, um, very easy to take the subway.
Um, but yes, like, I still, I, when we, when we, after the Broadway show and like dinner together, we went, we took an Uber back.
We took, we took a, we took a new, well, we took a, we were going to get tried.
a cat but there was no cats so we took an uber back because i was like i'm tired like because i was like i'm not i'm not taking this subway back i i feel like it's the later it gets the scarier the scare i was thinking i was like i was like there's there might be you know less people and it gets scarier so i was just like i feel like i feel like it would be safer to take the the the Like a card ride back.
Because I was just thinking.
I don't know what to expect.
For a late night subway.
Yes it does.
I don't.
I more.
Yeah.
More spawns.
There might be more spawns coming out at night.
It's like the night in Minecraft.
Oh yeah.
No.
The crackheads.
There were.
There were crackheads.
And the day.
I was like.
That's very brave of you sir.
But I guess like.
Doing crack stops for no one.
Apparently.
I thought There were I saw I was Luckily I was in a car When When that was When I saw when I saw one having a When I saw one crashing out Yeah Yeah It's It was like They are day walkers Yeah So So Yeah Crack never stops apparently So yeah No I saw one in a day Night During the day Not in the night So I was just like I'm like I got a little worried.
I'm like, if I see that's how they act in the day, I was like, oh my God, what's going to happen at nighttime?
Like, walking at night seems really scary.
So, yeah, so luckily, luckily I went.
We didn't take the subway at night.
We just, we took a car.
We took a car.
Anyway, but it was fun.
Comic-Con.
was um was very exciting we got to try out uh like i said we got to try out the newest resident evil game it was so cool we weren't allowed to take any photos i tried to sneak i tried to take a photo because i didn't see no photos i didn't see the no photos side um so so like i tried to take a photo and then the security guy was like hey no photos i was like oh I'm sorry.
I didn't know.
I didn't see it.
I don't read.
So, um, but like, um, but like, uh, the Resident Evil booth was so fucking cool because they have, it was like their own booth inside.
So it was like their own room that they decorated.
So it'll be a little bit of a spoiler.
Um, it'll be a little bit of a spoiler, but we did Onimusha first.
Um, but that's like on the outside.
So like, you can see everyone playtesting.
Onimusha, the Monster Hunter.
You can see see everyone playtesting the monster hunter game onimusha and pragmata but the resident evil game was like indoors like inside within the booth so like their own little room um so it was really cool because we didn't have to line up or anything um he's like you have to line up super early i'm pretty sure because they capped the lie and everything um so so they like uh so like we they were like oh what time are you coming over and then they gave us like time like what games do you want to play and i was like oh we want to play this this and this game and so they're like oh just come by the booth at this time and that time so we're like yeah that's cool we'll come over also uh silver thank you for the super chat thank you thank you hi dokey today's my birthday so i kindly ask you for a happy birthday from my favorite oshi no worries of course happy birthday to you happy birthday to you happy birthday dear silver happy birthday to you yeah happy birthday Um,
anyway, I'm hanging out with a super chat.
Thank you.
Anyway, so Um, we, we for it was so cool because the room was decorated like a hospital.
Um, so this is a little spoiler for the new Resident Evil game.
Um, I don't, the trailer doesn't really show it, but I think like, I don't know like where exactly the level is, but um, um,
the Onimusha playthrough, they said we could only play 30 minutes, so we got like really paranoid of being like, oh no, like, because the demo stops after 30 minutes, like you either complete the demo or the 30 minute thing, it like times up for you for 30 minutes.
So we got really paranoid because like we did Onimusha first.
So when we were in there, by the way, only one person can actually like play it.
to like the other watch so um I didn't play it for the Resident Evil because I was a pussy I was like I think you're gonna do me I because I didn't want to put the headphones on so I was like I was watching because I didn't I was a pussy um because it looked really fucking scary because like the newer Resident Evil games are actual like horror games compared to like you know So,
they actually made it so fucking scary.
The newer Resident Evil games.
It's no longer action.
It's just horror.
It's just...
So, we got really paranoid because we thought that...
Because, like, we weren't able to finish the...
Well, I wasn't able to finish the Onimusha demo.
I was literally still on a goddamn fucking boss fight.
um that when the demo stopped they're like sorry demos over um i'm still trying to kill the boss um so so during the resident evil uh game we got worried that we won't be able to complete it in time so we're just skipping the cut scenes because so but it was funny because we were led in first and then the regular people were led in after us because we got like you know they let us in first to the demo room and then later on the people who actually lined up showed up and but we're already like past we did a lot of it already we were only like one third past the demo um so we i was looking to the side i was like god damn that is a long ass cut scene that we missed that we skipped but yeah because we saw like we saw like 10 seconds 15 seconds of the cut scene and we're like skip because we're like oh what if we don't complete the demo in time um but i looked to the side and i saw this guy the guy next to us watching the ass cutscene that we skipped it was like literally a five minute
cutscene uh for the introduction um um for the intro to the demo and uh and so like i'll spoil it i don't even know where exactly we were in this game like it doesn't really tell you like you know because it's a demo so i i maybe it was the beginning but we you start out in the hospital and um and uh you're like trying to figure out how to fucking get out of the hospital like one area within the hospital and like you don't encounter a monster until like halfway and the monster itself is so fucking spooky it doesn't show i didn't i don't know if it came up in any of the reveal trailers but um she looked like i told dubie this i was because like um and i told her she looked like Lelorano.
Is that how we call it?
That, what is it?
You know that, that, the Lelorano, oh my god, Lelorano or something?
Um, is that how you pronounce it?
Lelor, um, but she looked like the monster version of her.
Um, you know, like the famous haunted house?
Okay, uh, there's like a haunted house, whatever, where she fucking eats a chat, like, okay, this is what show you like a picture of this and then like this is what she looked like um this is from a haunted house but like this is what she looked like to me but like it's like the whole body as well uh like I remember seeing a picture of this in a haunted house okay this is literally what she looked like to me like I was like oh my god it looks like her uh la your la yorona la yorona but like It's her entire body.
This is a haunted house.
But this is what that monster looked like.
But she's like afraid of the light and everything.
So...
And she's like really fucking big.
She's like really tall.
And she's afraid of the light.
So we had to do like a loop-de-loop and everything.
Oh, also she wasn't wearing shoes.
Just this is like very important.
So we looked at the toes.
like we're like that's so brave of them to have her not wear shoes like i remember i was like wow so brave capcon so brave to not have her wear any shoes uh so we we had to make sure we looked we did look um the actual horror um i had to check for all of you guys you know i was here for the people So brave showing her toes to the public But yeah,
no, like So you have to loop her around and stuff like that And then it was like a little mini puzzle with like using the light There's like, yeah, there's like lighter mechanic by the way Lighter mechanic is back There's lighter mechanic and And to loop around and she's afraid of the light So that's pretty good And then we finished the demo before the time limit too so i was like oh we should have just watched the cut scene if we are gonna finish it i was just like i was just like oh man we should have watched the cut scene i guess um but it was pretty interesting it looked really good um the new resident evil game because it it's like the other one the one with what's his name um i don't remember the guy's name you know the the Which is what I'm going to become soon.
Yeah, Ethan.
It's like his...
It's literally...
It's almost like...
I'd say it's more like Resident Evil 7 than 8.
Because 7 was...
I think 7 was more horror than 8.
8 felt more action-y.
I think.
Because like Ethan got...
Had like more mold powers, I guess.
I...
I guess he became more with the mold.
So he was more action-y in A.
But it definitely felt more like 7.
Felt more like 7.
Because it felt more like a horror game.
But like I said, we only did the demo for it.
And it was like one section.
So maybe it gets like more action-y later.
But the build-up was like more like you don't know what's going to happen.
Because there was just one enemy.
And you had to like stealth.
It was literally stealth.
in the beginning so like we didn't we couldn't kill anything the main character is a woman not ethan i don't remember who she is she's like related to someone i don't remember um i remember someone talked about who she's related to in the resident evil lore um i don't remember she's like some fun someone's fucking daughter i don't remember who she's someone she's someone's daughter i don't know whose daughter she is
hmm um so i she's a yeah she's a daughter of a character from outbreak yeah um she's also like a fucking pussy i guess because like it doesn't look like she knows how to use any weapons unless because i mean to be fair she was like locked up in a hospital so like it was like she didn't like she was like oh where am i and shit like that uh
like me she was a pussy like me um oh my god so much to talk about really a lot of stuff i mean i was gone for a while yeah she's an analyst so like i don't think she was there for any she was not in the field for any action-y stuff um let's see what else happened um oh i went to i remember i think it was joe's pizza pizza time i didn't realize that was a real thing i didn't Spider-Man.
I literally went to Pizza Tab.
So, in Spider-Man, by the way, that's not home.
He's still at the dog sitter enjoying his time.
I don't know if I should show the photos of...
Okay, so, I don't know.
But I'm jumping between a lot of times because a lot of stuff happened.
But...
You have to go to a new sitter.
This was a new dog sitter.
I had to try... That I contacted last minute because my usual sitter couldn't do it because it was Canadian Thanksgiving.
It's crazy when I told, like, to be about Canadian Thanksgiving.
She was like, why is it on a different, why is it, why is it on a different month?
Because I was like, and I was like, well, it's because in America, you guys had the whole like Pilgrims thing, you know, the infamous Pilgrim dinner thing.
Well, in Canada, we're just thankful, like, we're just, we're like, we want Thanksgiving too, we're just thankful.
I mean, that's how it goes.
Yeah, we didn't have that historical event.
We're just thankful.
Like, we want to be included.
Um, um, yeah.
Uh, just happy to be here.
Exactly.
Um, it's, I don't even, like, I don't know why it's on the, I don't know why it's on that particular day.
I just know we have our own Thanksgiving.
Uh, uh, uh, anyway so the the my current my usual dog sitter couldn't look after dad just because it's Canadian Thanksgiving so and they're already looking after another dog and they're like we don't know how this dog's gonna react to dad which is reasonable because dad's a fucking freak um he's unpredictable so um but so we put him at the new dog sitter and um and um He was like,
the new dog sitter, for some fucking reason, I tweeted about this, would send me pictures of him pooping.
And it wasn't like he was like almost done pooping or like he's about to poop.
It was like mid poop.
So like, but it's like one picture out of three that he sends every day.
But like every time he would send me, one of the pictures would be him mid poop.
Oh, but he did surprise me one day where he sent a picture of another dog that he was walking, pooping, and dad watching this other dog pooping.
It was a little surprise.
It was a little Easter egg.
Like, it wasn't dad this time.
It was another dog.
But dad's watching.
So I was so confused because I was like, I was just like, why are you sending me?
me these photos like a fun little side quest change it up a little bit fucking wild it was a wild thing um um zonder man thank you for the super chat thank you thank you way on canadian thanksgiving is objectively better what do you have to be thankful for in november balazar thank you for the super chat thank you thank you yeah i know exactly i was like the first time i was like second time I'm like oh okay you know I guess yeah it's still pretty silly and third time was when I got a little concerned I was just like okay maybe this is a little weird like this this is just this is just a little weird like um but now he's at he's back with the with his usual sitter now so like i'm getting him i'm getting him back tomorrow or maybe saturday depending on how i feel like i just want you know i want to cool down a little bit before i have to um before i'm being forced to be awake uh at seven in the morning to feed him so i just wanted to like you know i just wanted a little bit of a little
break before i had to go back to the routine that he established for me uh before i go back to his schedule um also i forgot to mention on saturday um I do have another sponsored stream on Saturday.
This time it's for PUBG.
So I just wanted to let you guys know in advance that we are going to have another sponsored.
It's on Twitch as well.
It'll be on Twitch.
So just giving you guys a heads up.
It's apparently something related to TwitchCon too.
Like I'll be playing with people at TwitchCon.
But I'll be here.
I'm not at TwitchCon.
I think I'm like one of the people who are not at TwitchCon.
I think like for me, I don't know.
I don't think I don't know if I'll ever go to TwitchCon because I personally think TwitchCon is more of like I'm not a very social person.
I like meeting people one-on-one.
I don't like doing groups and stuff I feel like TwitchCon is more for like people to it's more like a networking mixer type of thing Because the convention itself, I guess there's like like, you know, like there's like It's not like Comic-Con where there's like so many like big booths and like big gaming companies and like other like stuff like that I feel like like Comic-Con TwitchCon is more like a mixer event for like other streamers or for like,
you know, chat, like chat to like potentially meet their favorite streamer.
And I heard it was scary.
Like, not scary, but like people were like, I saw like lots of tweets about like safety measures of TwitchCon because like, you know, when you pack so many like celebrities, if you think about it, because it's, like, we're like, we're sort of like celebrities.
You pack a lot of like celebrity stuff into like one convention It does get a lot scary and like in terms of like safety measures and stuff like that So like that also like that's why I was like I don't I don't feel comfortable going to TwitchCon Um, and I've always hear like safety issues and stuff too at the convention But like yeah,
because like I had like someone friends asking me are you going to TwitchCon?
I was like, no, I'm gonna go to a comic con Also, it's easier to be incognito at Comic-Con compared to, like, TwitchCon.
Because I remember, I remember, like, I remember, like, asking, like, my friend, one of my friends, like, how, like, like, what do you do at TwitchCon?
Because I only went to TwitchCon once a long time ago, but that was just to, it was, like, a long, long time ago, but it was as an artist.
And I was just like I didn't do anything other than like go around the convention like I didn't do any fucking parties or anything Because like I heard there's a lot of parties too at twitch con too for like streamers and stuff So it's literally just like a mixer networking thing Where you can like network with other streamers and meet other streamers and you know meet your friends who are also streamers and stuff But like I said for me,
I prefer like one-on-one interaction like you know not like interaction like in a group and setting I prefer one-on-one like I do with Duby because um, I'm not I'm I'm an introvert so I'm not like a huge like talkative person in a group environment and I do feel like super uncomfortable too in a group environment so um especially like I'm worried about like getting docs too that's oh my god this is like so scary but like I remember like um I remember like during like I heard like there were stories of like other streamers doxing like other streamers like be like yeah you know that one that's actually that vtuber and I was like that's fucked up like I heard stories about that too because they were all like people were all at this one party I don't remember which party it was it was like I don't know like a partner's party or whatever or like a Twitch party um it was like it was one of the parties I don't know maybe it was like a v-shjo party or something because I think it could have
been the v-sh, like back then when v-shjo existed but like a v-sh-sh party and I heard stories of like other streamers were doxing others being like yeah like oh my god that's actually blah blah blah and stuff like that and I was like that's so messed up because it's supposed to be a private thing you're supposed to feel safe and everything um you're supposed to like feel safe in that environment especially when it's like a party for like other like for streamers that were invited by like you know by like um a company or like invite like that's being managed by this part but it's not it's not on b-show's fault it's just like there was no etiquette you know like you know there's like the guests it themselves weren't practicing and they love you know gossiping and stuff like that too um you know like gossiping and stuff so other like a streamer only event and I that's what makes me afraid of going to these events and going to these parties um because like why the like you know you're
going there because you you wanted to feel safe with other streamers but it's just how like other streamers would dox you know other streamers like you don't know this person is and you're like oh my god is this guy you know that guy he's actually this person and it's just it's just weird it's just it makes me so paranoid too yeah that's what i mean that's what i like um i like one-on-one socialization like socializing with one-on-one people people i know i don't want to be in a like a big ass group and i don't know half the people there yeah
I, yeah, so, so I don't know, I don't know if I ever wonder, if I'll ever go to TwitchCon, um, like I said, like, I know it's like more like a network, like meeting other people, networking and stuff like that, um, but, um, I'm really, I'm a really shy person in general,
and, um, also like, like I said, I'm very private, I'm a very private person, so that's why I don't like like um like if i i'm more likely to send a staff member at twitch con than me going myself like it was like oh hey if you want to talk to someone or meet up with someone like you meet up with like an event i actually do have a staff member at twitch con like because he's going there for himself but like i do have a staff there that is at twitch con right now so so so like if Like,
you know, if he wants to try and, like, network or, like, talk to any businesses or events and stuff.
I heard you can get a lot of free stuff, though.
If you're a partner and you talk to, like, the booths that's there at TwitchCon, apparently we tell them you're a partner.
They'll give you free shit.
That's what I heard.
So, like, I guess, like, there's that benefit, too.
Like, you get free stuff from, like, the booths and stuff that's at TwitchCon.
like um and everything um yeah
uh anyway what was I gonna talk about oh yeah um so um we didn't finish all of comic-con too we only did like half of comic-con which makes me really sad because I was like oh if I was here earlier if I didn't miss my flight we could have done more so I felt really bad um because I didn't realize how big it was!
It was...
Okay, Comic-Con was thinking it's...
Let me see if I can grab a photo.
I'll grab a photo.
I took a photo of Comic-Con of, like, how many people there were.
I didn't take the inside.
But I took, like, a photo of, like, me looking down.
Like, me just, like, seeing how many people there were there.
It was crazy.
I was not expecting that.
It's huge.
the biggest convention I've ever been to.
I don't think I've ever been to convention this.
I'm going to make sure.
Like, there's no.
It was literally the biggest convention I've ever been to.
And this was just like it was just me.
Like, there were so many people.
This wasn't even inside the exhibitor hall.
This was outside.
Like, the leading... And there's like two... Left side was the panels and right side was the exhibitor hall and artist alley.
And there were so many people, like, just outside and, like, just, like, walking towards the exhibitor hall.
Yeah, that's just the outside.
Also, it was raining.
Dubit loved, I learned a lot about her.
She actually loves, like, learning about the weather.
Like, just she loves, like, weather patterns and everything.
So she was, like, really hyped to see, like, oh, I can't, I want to see how the rain, how it looks like inside this convention hall while it's raining.
Um, so it was very interesting.
Um, also, like, you know, she loves aliens and stuff.
So, like, I didn't realize that she's a huge nerd about this.
But, um, she was giving me, like, insight about aliens.
Because she actually carries, like, a tiny telescope.
Like, those, like, little, like, those handheld telescope things to look for UFO sightings and stuff.
I thought it was so interesting.
I was like, oh, I didn't know that's, like, a thing.
yeah so she carries she carries like a little telescope and stuff to look for it see if there's any UFO sightings at night um and um and I like asked her about like she apparently she's she went through like Roswell and stuff too and I was like because she loves like no she she loves knowing more about like you know like aliens and stuff like that so I thought it was really interesting to like pick her brain about everything about like um um um Like,
I thought, like, you know, the alien stuff was, like, more like, just like a, I guess what's the word called?
Like, you know how I have, like, have a Doe Kitty and stuff like that?
You know, I thought the alien thing was just, like, a cute little gimmick, but it's, like, like, but she's, like, super interested in it, like, she's actually, like, really interested in it.
like actually like know so much because I was like picking her brain about like what she knows and like stories and stuff um and it was super interesting like I like I thought it was really cute that she carries a little telescope just in case there's a UFO sighting uh yeah yeah I thought it was just like an aesthetic gimmick thing like do kitty uh but like um but she's like super into the whole like paranormal stuff and uh the paranormal and um um and aliens so it's like really interesting to like hear her stories about it uh let's see what else uh but yeah we only did like 50 of comic con so i i really wanted to go back to comic con again um in the future because um i you know i i found it like really fun to walk around and like there were so many like interesting boosts and everything it was like
there was like um we we oh so she's like super into tomagachi i don't know if you guys know that um but um we passed by the tomagachi booth and oh my gosh i did not realize tomagachi has evolved so much um wait i took a picture of it because i was like what the fuck like
so i thought it was really cool because i was like oh my you can you can raise grogu like i didn't know that i was like oh my god i could have a little dwarf baby but she loves people we're looking around at the the tomagachi booth because i thought it was like uh i thought it was super interesting and i thought it was really funny that you can actually have your very own group group you can have Darth Vader you can raise your own Darth Vader in Tamagotchi and I took a picture of that I was like what the fuck your very own little Darth Vader
um so I had to take a picture of that because I thought that was pretty funny uh raise my own Yeah, there is!
It's literally Darth Vader Tamagotchi!
And there's, I mean, there's R2D2, but like, raise your very own Sith Lord.
Uh, your very own Sith Lord.
Um, um, but yeah, no, oh, every time we saw, like, um, during the artist's alley, uh, she bought a lot of, uh, Tamagotchi and alien merch and stuff, so it was really cute.
Oh yeah, and I saw, for those who didn't know, we saw this shirt and I was like, if I, if I'm buying this for you, would you, because I want, okay, so if you guys don't follow me on Twitter, I saw this shirt and I was like, do we, if I buy this for you,
would you?
Because I wanted to, I didn't, I wanted to match with someone, because I, so I'm shadow, I'm shadow and she's, Sonic and in the back there's like little wings and stuff to it.
It's so cute.
It's it's so it's so cute.
I love the dinners
so so we own these shirts now um what else oh my gosh oh wait let me go back from the beginning so there there was there there's a pizza story that's which is the real spider-man pizzas you know what peter parker does his delivery where he's like if you don't get your pizza in 30 in 30 minutes or less you get a free pizza so it's literally a real place like pizza time and like apparently a lot of celebrities actually go to that pizza restaurant so like there are photos of like All the celebrities that's been there like fucking Conan O'Brien Jimmy Fallon The rest I'm sorry I don't remember the oh the Ghostbuster guy forgot his name The Ghostbuster man he also there's like a photo of him too But apparently this place is like By the way um we were there at i think like 1 a.m and it was packed at one in the morning yeah bill murray there's a photo of bill murray there and uh we were there at one in the fucking morning at this restaurant and it was already like there was a line it was
packed inside and it was the morning i was not yeah they were full at and i was like if this is full at one in the morning i'm like thinking when the tourists are awake you know like that like actual tourists there um like um you would think that like it would be even worse like i was thinking about it i was like it would have been so fucking worse if it was like actual like morning or like you know at a regular time
so um so i was like it was i was like damn like i'm glad like i'm glad because apparently like you know when we're there it wasn't that it was still full but i was thinking like if it was like at an actual regular decent hour um um it would be a lot like it would be like a lot uh a lot more fully packed because of the tourists.
By the way, I forgot Columbus Day was a fucking thing.
Okay, so Jimmy and I weren't together all the time because she was with her aunt too because she brought her she brought her aunt a lot and her aunt is like a huge, also like a huge Broadway enthusiast.
So sometimes she was with her aunt and so sometimes I was exploring New York by myself.
So I went to the Museum of Ice Cream and Um, I was like wondering why there were so many fucking children like Yeah, I was like, don't you kids have school?
Like I was so I was so confused.
I was like, why there's so many kids here?
I was like, I was like, don't you have to go to school?
Like did you did your parents take you out?
some, like, just to fucking go to the museum of ice cream.
So I was like so confused.
I was like, why are so many children here?
Yes, but it's also a Monday.
I was like, it's a Monday.
So I didn't, no, they were, it wasn't like a field trip.
It was just literally parents, like parents bringing their kids.
So I know it wasn't a field trip.
It was like parents bring their children.
So I, I even said that a lot of myself, I was like, isn't it a school where there's so many children?
Isn't it a school day?
It was so confused.
And then later on, I found out it was Columbus Day because a lot of places were like closed or like closed early.
But I'm just like, how is Columbus Day a holiday?
I was so confused.
I was like, I did not realize Columbus Day was a real ass holiday.
day.
I thought you would still have to, I thought you celebrate like that day, like at school, because it's like an, it's like an educational day.
I didn't think like this, I don't know, I didn't think like actual businesses would like take the day off because I was like, what, I was just so confused.
I thought this was more like a school day, you know?
Uh,
uh school day instead of like an actual like day off like um um oh yeah let me show you guys joe's pizza wait let me double check i need to double check all photos just in case you know um but yeah here's joe's pizza see like see look at all the photos of the celebrity but also I seen you saw us in spider-man it's literally pizza time I literally came went to the pizza time restaurant uh yeah it was like a wall full of photos like um a wall full of uh photos of celebrities being like you're all the celebrities that went to joe's pizza um yeah it's like as seen in spider-man everyone looked at it I was like wait spider-man because like one of my friends recommended me um recommended me to check it out but i didn't realize because they're like this is one of the best pizza places in new york city so i was like i was like really oh man i was checking it out and it was like one in the morning and i was just like it's still open so uh
so i was just like i was just like yeah i was like spider-man wait i'm at pizza time i'm literally It was really good.
It was really...
I was so tempted because there was a little Italy tail.
It was like near me, near my hotel.
And I was so tempted to just like eat pasta every day.
But I tried not to.
I tried to like diversify.
So I had like, you know, I had...
I went to...
Oh, there was like this really cool Mexican place called Los Tacos.
It was so...
Oh my God, the tacos were so good.
I felt really bad because like there wasn't any gluten-free options.
so because dubia couldn't um couldn't eat it like she ate a bite she was like yolo out she had she had a bite but obviously um um she can't she couldn't have uh like she couldn't have like tacos because it's not gluten-free um and also there's like contamination too um so but she had of i was like uh because we thought there would be we didn't realize like they um we didn't realize like the the thing was contaminated and stuff so um with gluten because we were thinking like oh maybe there's gluten-free option but then we saw the kitchen and it was like all you know like the gluten-free stuff was going to be contaminated with the gluten stuff so we're like uh no like the thing is like we were the uh we were worried that it was contaminated you know like uh um like the gluten stuff would be contaminating the non-gluten stuff because it's all like in one kitchen so um so like we were worried about that so like she had like a bite and she's like yo yo yeah yeah so that's why we we didn't
want to risk it but it was good it was really good I don't have a lot of Mexican food because like I say um Mexican food is sort of Um, and then also like in my part when I was growing up here in Canada Um, it was also sort of non-existent here too because we are so north from the south like Like it's understandable because like um the west coast was so like because you know We're in the very north side of North America so
um um so it was like very far so there was not a lot of like mexican food or even like self-american food now there is now there is um now um but like back then it was like um it was like almost non-existent and um also like in asia too it was definitely not i wrote i told you guys a story before i know you guys are like taco bell doesn't count but um one time um a taco bell opened like um in shenzhen one time when i used to live in shenzhen um it opened it was like i've never seen a taco bell before this like in person i always see them in tv shows and i'm like oh my god is that a real thing um and a taco bell opened um in the city and it was the first time i've ever seen a taco bell like i i was living there already for like like I think like five years and then I saw a taco bell like it was a grand opening um it went out of business in one month uh it went out of business after a month it disappeared like
so yeah so that's what I'm saying like um um self-american food or like and even like Mexican food it's not very pop popular in in Asia so that's crazy like it's just like we're just not we just not used to it uh you don't say yeah I've never had a Baja blast before by the way I've never in my life still haven't I still haven't had a Baja blast um the lexer will change you in the highest state of gamer being Patio and Sue,
thank you for the super chat thank you, thank you I never grew up with it, so I never had a chance to um, oh my god what I did try out this one, Duby didn't wasn't, didn't eat with me, but um, we we tried out, okay, no, actually Duby said no I tried out because it was such a weird concept and he was like nah you can't go get there by yourself so it was french ramen and it literally just opened like they were they would been open for a week and it was called french ramen and i was like what the fuck is french ramen um i'm so confused and it was like apparently like uh michelin's chef from japan came to New York City to open this restaurant and like it's actually like um the chefs are Japanese so um I don't think they're doing very well I don't think so like it was so new that my Google Maps didn't even acknowledge its existence until like I because I was looking at restaurants because I was trying like be like what the fuck time is it open because it says 10 a.m.
and I was there and I was so confused and then the waiter the employee came in at 1030 like at um at uh 1015 and she was like yeah we open at 1030 now and I was like but it says 10 on the thing and it says 10 on the the Google Maps I was so confused so that waited at 1030 and then the chefs were coming in and then the chefs were like sorry we're opening at 11 a.m now and i'm like what the just like what what the fuck
because on the window it says 10 in the morning and the funny shit was was that in two days um in two days they had like this paper yeah sorry the time on the window is right they like got piece of paper and then wrote like and then taped it on the glass it was like 11 a.m to like that like it was taped two days later it was taped on the glass but they've been open for like a week already so i was so confused anyway for those who are wondering what the fuck is french ramen it's deconstructed ramen it's so weird i took it's it's deconstructed it ramen it was so fucking weird like that's what french ramen is let me double check the photo so like the toppings were like put on the side even i don't know it looks very french it it really did look very french look but i don't think the rest it was all right it was good But I don't think the restaurant's gonna survive like like this like this this is what I mean This is what I mean this is a French ramen um but I had by the way I had a
truffle I had a truffle um salmon wrap I know truffle by the way also it's truffle I thought the prop is truffle
The noodles under the Sabbath.
It was like, it was like $28.
But, but you can tell why Duby was like, I'm not coming here with you.
But I was so curious.
I was so curious.
I was like, what the fuck is French ramen?
Um, so...
Oh, yeah, it looks like a penis, too.
Yeah, it's the corn and the tomato.
So that's, yeah, she died because I was so curious.
I was like, what the fuck?
Because I kept passing it by.
I kept passing it by.
So I was like, oh, my God, I should really try this.
French ramen place because I need to know what the fuck is French ramen.
I had to know I
It was interesting.
It was all right.
It was good.
I won't say like it was the best ramen I've ever had It was all right.
It was just weird.
It was just so weird That's all I could explain it was it was so fucking weird because like they don't give you eggs to they don't give you like um the eggs like um with the ramen there's no you have to order it as a side topping so um so like okay here i ordered eggs and i also ordered an appetizer because i was just like fuck it why not so i ordered like some it was like beef with potato salad it was good though that shit was actually pretty good um but yeah so so it was like so i had to separately order the eggs as a topping and I also ordered like an appetizer with like a beef and the potato salad I don't fucking it was pretty good though it was pretty good and then I ordered I didn't realize that my ramen actually came with like beef because it said salmon and I could barely tell like what the okay so it came with like I could barely tell because like look at this it's fucking deconstructed ramen so they already had like a strip of beef and like a strip of chicken on the side
So I didn't realize, so I ordered a side of Tasu Because I thought that Or like pork, I guess that, I don't know, I guess I don't know, I think that was Tasu, I guess it was pork Because I couldn't tell I didn't realize that they already had So I ordered a side of dish of that Not like The pee-pee corn,
I mean look at it I think it was a rare gift so anyway so i had french ramen it was an experience because i was like you know when you're in new york city uh when you're in new york city uh you um it's you know you gotta try the weird shit too you know like you gotta you're in new york city you gotta try the weird fucking shit that the pretentious chefs make in that city like because it's like the only time you can so that was my that was my my one restaurant where i tried the pretentious like the french ramen uh because like i feel like this is the only place where it's like la like the quirky little restaurants you know little quirky things that you can get no i i didn't try to the cars the halal food because i did that like i did it when i was in the last time i was in new york city um it was a long time ago um you know like eight years ago last time I was there um I did I had I tried that once before and I don't I'm too scared because it depends on the cart you know like um because
I one time I tried a I remembered um when I was with a group of friends in New York City like eight plus years ago and um it was late at night and we're like we should get a hot dog and it was like the carts you know yeah the hot dog carts and is it very surprising that we got food poisoning right after like so i'm not i i i learned like you know i don't risk it anymore i i even we don't we don't risk that shit anymore like the cards that like yeah that sounds about right yeah so it's like a gotcha with food so i i'm not risking
yeah um what else i have so much stuff to tell you but i need to pee right now so i'll be right back
chat oh everybody i'm back oh thank you all for the super chats everyone oh my gosh uh allen meddy solid oh my thing stopped scrolling thank you the super chat thank you thank you netbirds parpo nexy bite uh jl forward papa Rice, Aphelion, Zechra, Smug,
Champion, Factor, Hey guys, JL, Yavi, 80, Medi, Klu, Pardipo, Kale, Red.
Oh, that's track.
Space, me, but JL again.
Kiko, thank you again for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
See, eventually I'm paying back for my Bob Swaski crystal.
Wait, what do I, what do I get it?
What do I get it right now?
on my desk wait it pays back see it let me let me get that actually no i let me get it right now
so cute it's like in a pink bag
pays it so bad guys oh my god oh my god the box is so silly yeah yeah yeah here we go let's see oh my god oh my god it has a certificate of authenticity
oh my god look it's not Papa I'll have it sit here to remind me that I spent $200 on this thing in my body Yay Of course it does They all shit Yippee It's a legit Bubba It's a Waski crystal Ha ha ha 269 nice um okay by the way um for those who are wondering what musical we actually watch we actually we were we were a bit basic um because like um was i was gonna be a it was some of some of you guys are gonna say that we're basic but uh we watched the lion king the lion king musical because it was like a musical that we both sort of always wanted to check out um because of like the the costume set the costume design um the costume designs and the set and i know like it won a lot of tony's when um it first came out so um i've never actually seen the lion king musical but i've seen uh I've seen like the sets the the costume design a lot because it it's been um it's been like um you know everyone has always gushed about the the the costume design of it because it's very unique in some way
it's very like not um not like traditional costume design um so so uh dubies aunt got us like insane tickets like we were basically like not like it was orchestra seats so we're not like front front but it was like a couple of seats behind the front um and we were in the orchestra seats too so it was really and it was in the middle as well so um her aunt got us um insane seats and i will say i almost fell asleep i was i almost fell asleep during act two good act one was so was really good act two i was like that was me because i act two act two was like so many slow songs it was crazy it was like act one had like it had all the hyped songs you know all the songs that we know Disney and um you know it was like act two it just had can you feel the love tonight and then it's all original songs but the original songs were like slow solo songs most of the time so I was like when it was like so like the slow ass solo songs I was like so um so like I was not feeling act two.
I loved act one though, because you know, it was be prepared.
Be prepared.
By the way, I was like too duby.
I was like, is Scargay?
Okay, if you guys, okay, if you guys can pull up the recording of be prepared, be prepared with Scar.
Drawing be prepared in the middle of it.
Out of nowhere There were like Half naked hyenas Like with their chest Bare chest Doing a fucking grave dance In the middle Like he just stopped singing And it was like Unce Unce Unce And then there were these like Cause like the hyena costume They were all just like Those like four-legged And then this was the one time The hyenas were on two legs Like standing up and dancing and then like and then like they were shirtless too So you see their abs and everything and it became a fucking rape club and they were doing some fucking Yeah,
and then they were just like and then scars just watching I'm just watching from the platform and I'm like Gay question, you know, like the screenshot.
I'm like the like straight you're like gay question mark
Men, they're all shirtless men, just winking It's like the game of the pride fly Yes, it's my Yeah, I was so confused Let me see if I can pull up the recording I was so good I was like, this is to do me, I was like Are you gay?
Like during the intermission And she was like, what?
I was like, no, you don't understand Let me see if I can find it Okay, okay, so Okay, let me see if I can find that exact moment.
Because I was, you don't understand.
I was so confused.
Because it just, it's here.
It's here.
Oh my God, it's right.
Because they were singing the song.
And so I was like, what?
And then they were shirtless too.
So you can see their abs and chest.
I was so confused.
It's right here.
No, you don't understand.
Look at this.
Oh my god, look at this and don't tell me that was so fucking weird.
I, I was so, like, I was not prepared for this part.
I was so, I was not prepared for this because I was like, be prepared, like, you know.
I was like, oh, I love this song.
And suddenly now I was in a, I was in a rain.
I don't think this is canon.
I was like, where was this in the movie?
Everything the rainbow touches is our kingdom raging.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Not prepared.
He said pre-prepared and I was clearly not.
Now you understand, right?
Guys, now you understand.
I was so confused.
Okay, I understand.
understand now you really
because they were the only also they were the only hyenas um where they were the only hyenas where like they were on their two legs like they were standing on their feet the other ones were like uh the other ones were like um um like you know just crawling around four feet but this was like the only the only hyenas that were just fucking dancing like um so yeah so so there was that and um and then okay there was a really weird song in there where um scar was like I need a mate and then like uh Nala comes along and he was like you'll be my mate and I'm like bro what I was just like what I was like that was not in the movie I was like excuse excuse me that was definitely not in the movie oh my god I was like oh I don't remember That part I know she gets together with some of that Scott Yeah,
I'm glad Disney cut it because I was like, that's a little problematic I was like, I was like, that's a little problematic Bro Yeah Um Um But yeah, so it was really It was, I thought it was, I love, okay, also, um, I love, I really love the costume design,
though, costume designs were so interesting, because they were, they, they were wearing these, like, helmets of, like, the lions, and then they can, like, move it up and down, to, like, when they're fighting, um, when they're fighting, the mask moves down to their face and stuff,
so it was, it was so interesting, I, I don't know, I really, I really love the costume design um for the movie it was so cool and the puppetry too so um like the puppetry was super cool too because like uh um oh my god there was this one lady that was trying to be ants and she was wearing like a dress of ants and she was just swirling like like mofaso was like look at these ants and then like literally this woman comes out with like like a cone shaped ant twirling around to to replicate the ants like crawling around here and I'm like what the fuck he's just like yeah he's like twirling around with all the ants I'm like what the fuck it's so silly it was so fucking silly um terminator they use super chat thank you thank you do you see is african inspired travel dancing no it doesn't no it was not Look,
that was not, that was not tribal dancing.
There was no way, I didn't, watch that clip.
There was no way that was tribal dancing.
There's no, they're doing parietz and shit, bro.
They were doing, they were fucking doing parietz.
Um, um, um, anyway, my tribe, that's, anyway, I also went to a comedy club, um, because, you know, I felt like in New York City, uh, oh yeah, I forgot to show you guys a photo, by the way, let me, uh, let me get that photo, I didn't save it yet, let me grab it,
um, the photo of, the photo that, Doobie and I took, in front of the Lion King thingy.
Uh, which is, I'll do this one.
We gotta crop our fingers out.
We're like Victorian women.
We're like, we show a little ankle.
Like, can't, can't show that.
We gotta crop our fingers out.
Can't be showing that.
You know?
scandalous wait oh my god they have an ai erase why did i just erase her fingers it's gonna look okay so i did that for one of the pictures but it looks so freaking freaky because i erased a child in my photo so it looks like a goddamn ghost it looks like a ghost okay wait i want to show you guys it's from the ice cream museum because i wanted to show you guys pictures of it guys it's not um It's not like,
um, there's no, there's no ghost here.
I was just trying, there was an AI eraser that Windows have now when you're editing photos.
So I was trying to erase a child from my photo because of, you know, like consent laws.
And like, I feel weird having a child on my stream.
And then I look like a goddamn ghost who showed up on my camera.
Do you see it?
Did you, did you, do you see it child erase from existence?
Did you see it?
I was trying to erase it.
I was trying to, I was trying to AI erase it.
It looks very bad.
The ghost of banana-past...
Broca replaced by AI.
He's part of the art now.
Getting a banana pie.
Anyway.
Here's a picture.
We were here.
The Lion King.
That's why Duby was singing that in karaoke.
That's why she was singing it because we literally, we literally watched the Lion King musical.
Um, yeah, it's cute.
It's so cute.
There's us right here.
Yeah, there's us.
And then we had like Latin American food right after.
It was so good.
She like, what is it called, Papadel?
No, it's a Papapapai.
I don't remember what it's called.
But she was like, we have to get this to share.
It was like this rice seafood dish.
It was so good.
Oh my, I don't know.
I don't remember what it's called.
Um, what was it called?
It starts with a P where it was basically like, uh, Paella?
Paella?
Yeah, she was like, we have to get paella.
Is that how you pronounce it?
She was like, we have to get it.
Because like, we saw someone on their table eating it.
And you're like, it's a really good...
Like, usually you eat a shared...
Like, you eat a shared dish.
Um...
With a bunch of...
Like, with a bunch of friends or family.
And, um...
And, like, we ordered it as, like, a shared dish.
And it was so good.
Oh, my...
god it was at it was so we both hated the muscles though because we're not none of us were in muscles people so we didn't do that but oh my god it was so good oh it just sucked because like if our hotel room had a fridge i would have um i would have like kept it for like the next day um but we we didn't have a fridge so um so we couldn't eat it yeah but Oh my god.
Describes a dish.
Oh, it was, well, the restaurant itself said it was like Latin American.
That's what the restaurant, like the restaurant description is.
It was like Latin American food.
So I just assume it was also Latin American.
Next seat, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
So I didn't know it was Spanish.
because the restaurant itself said Latin American.
So I thought it was also Latin.
It was, I didn't realize it was from Spain.
It's a common, oh, Paia is a common dish in Latin America.
There we go.
I don't know much about, I don't know much about like, because I was so, I was so north.
And also so, I lived in a lot of places that was very far away from South America.
So I don't know much about like Latin American food or just like, Spanish food in general because I was so far away.
I never had the opportunity to try a lot of these dishes out.
So like Duby was introducing me a lot to like, um, to like self-American food or like Spanish food in general.
Um, because I don't have a lot of experience.
Uh, I don't have a lot of experience eating these types of food in general because I didn't grow up with it.
Um, but it was so good oh my god it was i wish i want more i want more of that uh yeah and then she was talking to me about like these dried chips i don't remember what it's called um because it's very common also in south america um what are these there was these like dried chips um i don't remember what it's called uh uh plantains yes plantains yes Yes,
I think plantain chips.
Yes, yes.
Those were good.
Because she was like, oh, you gotta try plantain.
Like the stuff inside the plantain.
And also the chips itself.
And they were really, really good.
Yeah, she was like introducing me to...
To all of it.
Also, apparently she told this story before.
But I didn't know about this story.
I'm going to tell this story to you guys.
For those who don't watch Doobie.
But she said she told this story before on stream.
And...
basically when she was like while we're eating we were talking about like um you know our personal life and stuff like that like you know like where we came from and stuff like that so we got we're getting to know each other a lot more and she was like oh yeah like um when she was younger um she had access to like you know she did her own thing in the piece on the PCs at school so you guys might remember this story I did not know like I did not know this story so um she would like you know fuck around on the PCs at school and um during one of those times she found acts like she realized she could talk to like um I guess like FBI I don't even know like police officers or some shit I know it's like she found like those like chat yeah the recruiter yeah it's like a to like recruiters on the websites and stuff as a live chat and then she was like there's a bomb like she was like i have a bomb at this school i have a bomb at this at this school and then the recruiter was like this is not a
joke this is where i have your ip address right now and like the recruiter gave her like the IP and then and like um she made a bomb thread when she was like young like um I think like elementary slash middle school she made a fucking bomb thread and then the recruiter was like this is not a joke this is your here's your IP address
And then she just like closed the website instantly the moment the recruiter gave her IP, she closed the, she closed the chat.
And I straight up told her, I was like, were you on Newgrounds, kid?
I was like, I'm like, were you on Newgrounds, kid?
Because that's the only explanation I could think of.
I'm going to make a fucking bomb threat.
And then she was like, no, I'm never.
actually never been on new grounds I was like holy shit I was the most holy thank you for the raising thank you surprisingly surprisingly she's never been on new grounds before which was the most surprising fight for me yeah yeah that was yeah I'm only telling the story because like Apparently she told a story before on stream.
I was like, holy shit, you're wild, girl.
You're fucking wild.
Um, um, Uzuro, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Um, you'll be in her when I was a kid story.
So we're flying as usual.
She's on the list, man.
That's crazy.
That school is on.
the list not her but that fucking school is on the list after that um nexus thank you for the super chat thank you thank you what was up with that breakfast it was just a breakfast restaurant um i like how people were like is that your last meal like because i was like last day it sounded so ominous like last day we were like wait what's gonna happen to her um it's just a breakfast place There was,
like, a lot of really, um, good breakfast places around New York City.
Okay, like, I fucking hate the traffic, though, in New York.
That was, like, other than that, it was a lot of really, yeah, my last supper.
There's a lot of, like, really, um, really good places to eat around New York City.
Like, ah, if I could have stayed a couple more days, I would just be eating.
I'd just be exploring the restaurants around.
Hmm.
Okay.
Um, wait, let me...
Do I still have any more cough drops?
Check.
Where are my cough drops?
I swear I had another box of them.
I guess I don't.
I swear I did.
I guess I was wrong.
Oh, well.
I ordered more later.
Um, oh yeah.
Anyway, I went to a comedy club.
Um...
in new york city um i did i bought like two boxes but i don't know where i put them um this is why this like i said this fucking this trip was a wake-up call i was i'm a mess uh baby koala i think it was super chat thinking thank you yes i went to a comedy club um uh uh db didn't come with me um because it was also really late it was like 11 30.
i went to 11 30 show because it was the only show um that was available on that day so because I was like you know when you're in New York City you have to go to a comic it's like such an iconic thing because it was like I went to the seller the comedy seller which is like the most famous comedy club because like I was hoping you know like like it's hoping like oh maybe a really maybe like you know a celebrity comedian will show up you know because sometimes um if you're really lucky also it didn't happen if you're really lucky a celebrity commute like a big celebrity comedian might show up um for one that shows you know to do a set because they sometimes visit the comedy seller because a lot of them um um a lot of them like had their start um at the comedy seller so it's like the place to go um it was really okay what was really crazy was um um they like take your phones by the way uh you're not allowed to go in with your phones because they don't want you recording anything because
sometimes i guess like um because like by the way new yorkers love to talk to people like fucking talk to strangers uh
they love to talk to strangers um is they're like oh is this your first time i was like yeah This is my first time here and basically the reason why is that some comedians there They they like try out new sets or like try out new bits and stuff and they don't want that recorded So like if it's real it's a really bad joke.
They don't want that recorded or anything So so that's why they they have you like Lock your they basically give you like this little envelope and you have to seal your phone it um yeah they're like testing the waters before it gets recorded like before they make a special and everything anyway i'm gonna steal two jokes from them um there were a lot of sets like it was like i think like it was like seven comedians that day for my the show i wasn't i um it was so long because like i left that like like it started at 11 30 and i left that two in the morning um but There were two jokes I really liked,
and I really was, okay, so, um, one of them was, okay, I'm, me retelling it might not be as funny, but I was like, holy fuck.
So, one of them was that basically, um, um, she has a friend that she's like, oh, he's like such a bore, but like, I, um, but like, you know, he's part of the group, and then she was saying, like, how, like, yeah, because all his, like, his parents died,
like, all his family died in some freak accident.
And I was like, holy fuck, right?
And then I was like, I was like, what?
Just like, yeah, there's my friend, one friend, like, you know, we can't really abandon him because God abandoned him.
Like, I was like, holy shit.
So, you know, he might be like really a pain in the ass or like really boring, but like, I'm helping.
I'm like, I'm thinking, can't abandon him.
Like, Jesus Christ, I started to choke off strong.
The punchline was, like, I can't abandon him because God abandoned him.
Because I was just like, Jesus, fucking Christ.
He's such a, yeah, he's like, yeah, sometimes he's such a buskill.
Like, I was just like, oh my God.
Yeah, he was like, it's my charity to the world.
Yeah, I'm like, oh my God, it's crazy.
and then um the other one was like oh my god okay this is so fucked up like you know like some comedians they're asked the audience and stuff by the way it's crazy because like we had some weird like not weird people we had some very controversial like um topics and stuff and then like one of the you know when they ask like guests and stuff like where are you from and then so like on the left side because I didn't want to sit in the front row because like I don't want them to ask me anything like I'm too scared I don't know what they're gonna say so I didn't sit in the front row because they were doing crowd work and stuff so like they're um they're like asking people around and stuff and like you don't know what you're gonna get so on the left side there was a guy from Albania and then on the right side there were three guys from Saudi Arabia so Obviously,
people were like, oh, shit.
There were three guys on the right that were from Saudi Arabia.
And so it was very interesting.
It was like...
Oh, dear.
And then, like, I remember the first comedian.
They're like, okay, cool.
And then, like, let's change topics.
Like, oh, that's cool.
All right, let's change topics real quick.
They're like, we don't want to, they're like, oh yeah, I don't really, I don't know if, I don't know, I don't know if I'm gonna touch that right now.
Yeah, yeah.
He was not, he was not ready.
And then, we're the same comedian, because like, um, uh, the same comedian, um, he was like, talking like, he was bald, and he was like, oh, I love hearing, like, stories about how someone, like, when they got when people get bald and then um and then he was like sir when was the uh when were you bald and then the guy was like at the day after 9 11 and i'm like what the fuck
like he says that like the day after
nothing oh my god you're a never forget he's never gonna forget like we're in New York City by the way we were in New York City um so so like obviously we were like what the fuck like the computer's like what do I do like with that answer and and then and you know you struggle let's let's change topic guys oh my gosh and he's like like why like he was like hey i gotta know bro why where did you go all the day after that where were you and then the guy was like oh i was in australia i was like bro you were in australia that's how that's even corley you weren't even in your ex-city somewhere else he's like bro what What the fuck?
I thought it was like a traumatic event.
You were in fucking Australia?
I was just like what the fuck bro had a punchline and everything That's actually Yeah, he was missing it was where the fuck is the connection like
I got proud of you for trying to make an emergency landing strip.
Golden, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
He's scared.
He was scared.
He was like, I was in Australia.
Just because he's Australian doesn't mean he don't bleed red, white, and blue.
Guys, it is never forget, guys.
Never forget.
so yeah so that that's what happened i mean there was a lot of comedians but those were the two moments at the comedy club that like stuck out for me they were two really good moments i really wanted uh i really want to do i wanted to go to the show before because they had a writer from they had a writer from like um from a famous like show so I was like super curious like it was I was super curious and interested on like like it was oh it was like a writer from the Dave Chappelle show so um it wasn't Dave Chappelle it was a writer from that show so I was super curious because I was like oh maybe what kind of sets is he gonna do but it was all sold out and like apparently like there's standby tickets but you have to like You have to be like,
you have to line up at that like early for it.
Like you have to be at the door early and just like see if you can, see if you can like grab a ticket like on like on this like at the door.
Like if it's because like you can reserve it.
I don't remember the name.
I just was looking at the description as to who's doing it.
Because I don't really know a lot of like local stand-up comics.
I just know like you know like the celebrities you know I don't know a lot of the writers and stuff I just know like you know the celebrity comics So and look how you guys were like oh, that's Neil Brennan.
That's You were like that has to be him.
So So yeah, unfortunately, I couldn't gravitate.
I didn't want to wait in line, too Because I was like, you know, it's just like I don't want I don't like waiting in line Unless I have a reservation already because you can reserve it through email Um, and you don't have to, you don't have to, like, pay up front.
You can just reserve it through your email and then just show up and then you pay later.
Uh, so, so, like, obviously, like, it's very easy to reserve a ticket because you don't have to worry about it.
Um, but yeah, no, it was a very interesting experience.
I did a lot of stuff that, oh my gosh, I've been yapping for two hours.
I swear to God, guys, like, I did so much in New York City.
like experiencing things than like buying stuff or like sightseeing i went i was i went more for experiencing new york city rather than like like just sightseeing or like um like i want to do stuff you know like i mean to be fair watching like doing what going to a comedy club isn't really like it's like not really like it's still like watching something but it's different from sightseeing um but i really god i really wanted to go to um i really wanted to go to a showing of like a late night show or like saturday night live but i was reading up on it and it's so fucking competitive like because you can't you can't even get scalp tickets for it because it's um because it's like linked to your id so you can't even get scalp tickets for like saturday night day night live or like any like show like late show uh like up on it too um apparently like the only way you can even potentially um grab a ticket uh for like saturday night live or something is that you have to like line up um the day
before and even then it's not guaranteed because it's more so of like how like like how many people would be able to get it you know you have to like do a line the day before to get the extra tickets god i need like a cough drop oh fuck oh wait i have oh my god i have one more oh my god i found one oh my god there's so i have like five more yeah so and i was reading up on it and people were like oh if you're lucky you might bump into like uh you might bump into there's like five more I found like a little path.
Bump into like the musicians or like the workers at SNL and maybe they'll give you a ticket for free.
But only if you're lucky.
And it obviously, it depends on like who's hosting, you know?
Because, you know, if it's like a big celebrity, a lot of people would be like, would be super competitive about going to SNL.
And I was reading up on it.
sold they sell it on charity auctions too so then i went to the fucking today i went to a fucking rabbit hole of like charity auctions and then i because they were linking i'll show you guys the website they're linking this website being like oh sometimes i put tickets on this website so I got into a deep rabbit hole like today about it and oh my god guys guys it's only 250 dollars for now for now but like guys I could own a Tony Hawk side skateboard I'm looking through all these I am guys what have I been on a Tony Hawk side skateboard deck oh my god I know what if I could guys I could get I could get a toria and then I saw this oh my god look no I saw this and I'm so mad because I'm so mad because I low-key was about to bid on this on a Hugh Jackman will record your personal outgoing voicemail I was like oh I can ask him to give me a shout and I looked at the terms and conditions and he was like this outgoing voicemail is for personal use only this message may not be used for any
business and or the sale of any new commodity is not used by any means as an endorsement or any person and or bread because I couldn't do it I was like oh I can't he won't be able to shout me out I can't get it I can't get it you Jackman uh voice pack I mean I can't play it on stream because it's considered a commodity it's considered a business expense I don't want you Jackman to get to go after me guys I can't play it on stream they said it It has to be a personal voicemail.
It would have been so funny.
I was so close.
I was so close, guys.
Also, the Grammy, there's a Grammy.
You can literally go to the...
Guys, guys.
Okay, if February 1st I, like, disappeared, you know where I am.
If on February 1st, I'd suddenly disappear and I was like, I'm going to go on vacation.
You know where I am, guys.
You know where I went.
To be fair, I don't listen to music that much.
I just thought it was so cool.
I was like, the Grammys?
Oh my God.
Maybe Daft Punk.
Guys, what if Daft Punk makes a guest appearance at the Grammys?
Guys, imagine.
What if, guys, what if Daft Punk makes a guest appearance?
Guys, this is my only chance.
This is my only chance.
chance what if they start saying get lucky
jacquardo thank you for the super chat thank you thank you um joki doesn't want to get into the battle with the wolverine so getting you jackman was out of the question maybe next time there will be a next time thank you for the super chat thank you thank you next see so glad you had such a good time and got to do so much thank you the super chat thank you thank you definitely it was definitely really fun though but yeah i got into this random rabbit hole about charity options because i was like bro i could go to the grammy's i could i could own a tony hawk side skateboard deck he ain't getting any younger it's like stan lee guys it's like the stan lee thing but like now for his skateboard
Oh my god.
Wait, uh.
Oh, it's been, it's been a wild.
Uh, it's been a wild time.
I've been like, uh, hmm.
But it's Tony.
Hawk don't understand Leo TX game.
Let's see.
I'm trying to like...
Look through everything real quick of what I want to talk about
But no, no, no, no, no, no, no No, no, no, no, no, no Oh, yeah, by the way, next week we're going to announce the Jokey Jam winners Um, it took us a while because my schedule was so fucked And because I wanted to have a stream to do more about the Jokey Jam stuff Um,
and then my schedule got really fucked up I'll tell you how it's gonna go Um Well actually I shouldn't tell you that's how it goes I'll tell you guys how it goes on that day So we're gonna be announcing that next week For people So I took a really long time So I took like a month or so To announce the winners Like I said We're deciding how the winners would be done And also like Obviously I didn't have the time to try all the games So the Joki Jam team We're trying out all the games to pick,
to help, like, decide.
There will be, I think there will be six winners.
I think it's six.
It's either six or five.
I gotta look through it again.
So I really apologize about that.
But we're gonna announce it next week.
But, yes, the Doki Jam team played all the games to have, like, an actual, to have, like, a good idea of how the judging was.
the games because like i did not have that time but i will be playing after the jokie jam announcement winner winner announcement i will also keep playing the games too um so um so that it won't be like the last time we see the game so i'll still continue playing it it's a lot there was a lot of games i really appreciate all everyone uh working so hard and being so fucking creative and creating all these amazing games.
I went to the Wax Museum.
Um, um, I thought it was, okay, so there was this one area at the Wax Museum.
Um, okay, the Wax Museum freaked me out a lot, because like, I don't like animatronics, but like, I realized that my newest fear is the Wax Museum.
Um, so so there was there was i'll show you this is the this was the one area that freaked me the out because i was not okay and it was it was literally the cats area so this freaked me out Because they were too close.
Because like, they're not human at that point.
I actually could not.
Like, I was so fucking scared.
Like, I actually had goosebumps and everything.
I had to, I did not feel safe.
I did not feel safe whatsoever.
And I had to make sure that's because this actually, I was getting goosebumps.
And I was so scared.
they're actually gonna come alive and fucking eat me um so i had to wait until i see other people walking through for me no this is the musical cast it's not the live this is not the live action this is the musical version but i had to wait for like other people to walk in front of me for me to go past this area because i was legitimately so scared i was like i felt like it just it was just not okay and they were just too close like like they were way too close for my liking um but um there was so many uh cool wax feet oh my gosh wait i got we have to show you this picture i took so many photos because that is so it's so fucking stupid i took so i this was like i'm surprised like i did not get caught Mr. Abe?
Oh my god.
Abraham Lincoln is a dragon, guys.
I...
I took...
And then I also have...
Not only do I have Abraham Lincoln, but I have...
Um...
Wait, but I also have...
No way, Mr. Lincoln.
but I also have these Steve Jobs I have I have these Steve Jobs as well historically before he went a little cuckoo and started sticking shit up his ass to cure cancer okay here's a little fun fact but you know how Steve Jobs got diagnosed with cancer well he wanted to try like was it holistic is it called holistic medic medicine he wanted to like try to like not do like um not use like actual like modern medicine to cure from cancer um so one of the ways he tried to like he tried to use like natural medic like natural medicine not like modern medicine So,
one of the, yeah, what's it called, homeopathic medicine?
So, one of the things he did was that he stuck some shit up his ass, hoping that it'll cure his cancer.
And he's dead now, so, I don't think it worked.
Yeah, he tried, like, essential oils and stuff like that.
Yeah, so, um, and then finally, the thing is, The craziest shit is, is that his cancer wasn't even, like, it wasn't terminal, like, because it got caught early, and, like, he had, I don't remember which cancer he got, but he had the one that wasn't terminal,
and, he could actually, like, he could actually, like, get, get, not cured, because he can't cure cancer, but, what's the word called?
of actually like uh i don't remember what it's called he could survive yeah there was a chance he had a high percentage to survive so then he was like i have time like so he was like i clearly have time because it was diagnosed super early it was an early stage um so so what he did was he stuck some stuff up his ass and it didn't work and then later on he later on after it progressed really far up he was like okay now i'll get chemo but it was already too late like it was already too late so yeah guys don't all i say is like if you have access to modern medicine
Don't, don't, don't, don't, don't like gamble with your life.
Like, don't gamble your life like that.
Like, sticking things up your ass is not going to work for cancer.
It definitely wouldn't.
Yeah, listen to your doctor about that.
I'm sorry, Steve Jobs, but like, that's something we all have.
That's like something we have to learn in life.
Like, you already listened to us all.
that's that's a lesson to us all about some things that we shouldn't do uh okay and all right so okay this one's crazy okay so i need you guys to know about this one particular section and um it was okay so i was in the so you saw like me with abraham lincoln so that was the president hall so it was like there were all the presidents and stuff and all like world leaders and so like like fucking Gandhi was there too like not not like he's dead but you know what I'm talking about the wax museum so right after that you go outside the room and then it leads you to a subway entrance and I I need you guys to know about the subway entrance like and stuff let me make sure the reflection and stuff real fucking quick um because i just gotta be sure um okay so so like from the president hall to like by the way let me show you what the president let me show you like it was so like bright and everything And then,
and then right after the exit to the prison hub, we're like in, like, whatever the fuck this is.
So, I was just like, what the, by the way, the lights were flickering.
By the way, so I knew this was a.
bad this was a bad subway this was a fucking bad subway like they had the flickering lights and everything right after i got a presidential i got a photo with um with mr obama and joe biden like like okay look at the comparison because because i was just like oh my god i can be the president
guys this is like let me show you guys this is actually crazy the the the dual image of like how bright everything was and then and then like this was like the last photo i took in that hall in the in that room and then straight up we went got into the creepy fucking subway entrance so like look i'm like look at me i'm i'm now i'm president of the united states and then right after you go to the right and then and then it's the murder subways it's and then and then it's like the murder subway you turn right murder subway so so so i was like i was so scared because and then what did not help um was that was that as you go down the stairs because there's no other way you have to go this way as you go down the stairs on the right you see these posters they were horror movie posters so like it was like it and the conjuring and the nun so i was like oh this is a bad This is a very bad This is a very Very bad subway
So I do well as I was like Oh no This is the horror part of the wax museum So Do spooky freak toky So I waited in the stairs I waited Because the lights were flickering I was like why the fuck is the lights flickering so I waited I waited for for the stairs like for people to like start going down the stairs so I could like you know so I could also go down the stairs and then literally to the there's like there's like a left and a right so the left is for the pussies which is where I went and just and the right is for Warner Brothers horror like special horror exhibit so obviously I went to the left because I ain't gonna fuck with that like I'm no person that didn't go to the to the fucking murder scene to get murdered by I don't know Jason um so so I went to the left um and even then The left was so,
like, it led me to Ghostbusters, but like, not the, it was, but not, like, the classic Ghostbusters, it was the one where they gender-bent the Ghostbusters movie, but even then it was spooky, because there was, like, the slime guy, but, like, it was so loud,
and everything, so I was getting even spooked by the, the comedy, Ghostbusters.
But I could hear the noise of the horror attraction, because...
Because you have to go through that.
To like.
Okay I'll show you guys.
Wait let me check if there's any reflections.
I'll show you guys.
So like there was like a hologram of the slime guy.
And then you can like.
You can like push a button or something.
To like capture him.
But it was so fucking loud.
And also like I hear like bits of the other attraction.
Like the horror.
Like so this is what it looks like.
So it's like the hologram.
The hologram of the slime.
And then you can like on the right side, there's a button That you can push to like suck the slimer into the thing.
But it was so loud and I hated it because I was just also standing there by myself.
So I was just, it was just me and the slimer.
And I was just like, I was so scared.
So I wanted, because I was like, what's downstairs?
I don't know what's downstairs.
I don't want to go into the other room by myself.
video of like what was in the okay madam uh warner bros horror i looked at the video of the the exhibit it was so bad it was i don't think i i definitely for sure would not have made it i i would have for sure not been okay if i went there because like their own room that you go through and I knew looking at the looking at the photos and the videos I would not have been okay I would have 100% been not okay if I had to go there I had to go through this I'll show you guys so I like cuz I looked out cuz I was so you know I was curious I was like oh I didn't go but i wanted to know so like basically like i would not have been okay if i saw this in person i would i would not have been also they have the it they have it in step penny wise too so so like yeah and they're all wax too yeah yeah no i would not have been okay they also have like penny wise too so look at that i would not this if if i couldn't do the cats i was struggling with the fucking cats i would have oh my god this would
have been so bad
and like i watched a video and each room jump scares you they Blast you with air and like apparently with a I was watching a video of it of them walking through And they like blast you with air between each room and like and with a jump like a jump scared sound effect To when you go to each room and like I would like this already is not good for me But the fact that you get blasted with like a mini jump scare when you enter a room was not not Not okay.
But it was a...
It's a Madame Tussaud New York wax museum.
I mean, it was cool.
It was very... It's so realistic, bro.
It was...
I was just...
Oh, my God.
I took so many photos of...
I took a lot of photos.
Oh, my God.
Wait, I need to show you guys this one.
I love it when...
Okay.
I'm saving this right now.
I'm saving these photos I took.
Where is it?
This one.
Every time they stick out their hand.
I was like, it's perfect.
It's Loki bird.
I thought it was so funny
Loki bird Also Also this one too This one No you guys Oh my god I would steal your Caption oh my god I should have like Cause I was like oh what do I caption What do I caption this and then I love someone Was like um Um why didn't you ban Hulk And don't keep playing while this is what happens to your support in the back line like one day I'm gonna repost this photo and york one of your captions like it's so good It's when you don't feel for your supports.
Yeah, that's so good.
I'm gonna repost this one day I just so I can use that caption
I went to Flavortown.
It was not Flavortown in Flavortown.
I got so sad.
Guy Fieri really did fell off.
I went to, there was a, there was like a Guy Fieri restaurant, fast food chain, and I was like, I gotta go.
I gotta go to Flavortown.
It was not Flavortown, unfortunately.
I was so sad.
I felt like, don't ruin my impression.
It was so, it was, unfortunately, I did not, I was not taken.
Look, there's Guy Fieri.
Unfortunately, I was not taken to Flavortown.
Look right here, see?
Wait, let me check if there's any reflection real quick.
Look, see, Flavortown.
I had to take a picture of that, though.
I didn't do Flavort.
It was like a fast food chain.
but it was still pretty bad.
It's Parasimdrome but Flavortown.
It made me so sad because I was so looking forward to Flavortown.
We didn't share rooms.
We got different rooms because Duby brought her aunt along.
Oh my god, there was this really cool exhibit where it was like for free too.
It was for free.
And it was basically like I don't remember what the place was called but they had like you can go in for free and they host like events and stuff um or like um they host like um like anime watching or like like it was like a little Japanese manga library thing where they had like little art galleries of like different types of manga uh art galleries so there was like Attack on Titan Ghost in a Shell Blue Lock and stuff like that and it was all free entry and it was so cool and they had like a um they had a giant diorama of the attack on titan um village and you know what that you know what i did for it that was the most riskiest photo i've ever taken honestly that had to be the most risky photo i've ever taken but you know what i had to do
That day, humanity had a grim reminder.
An attack on Dokey Bird.
Oh my god.
I had to take that photo and then it had to be done.
The Dokey Bird Titan right there.
How did you get your Titan there?
buy my merch did you know that donkey blade is still up for pre-orders buy my merch or you get eaten um yum yum surprisingly he uh the walls were thick enough for him but i was so surprised that it actually my plush he can actually sit down there um also okay judge me okay it's like tradition at this point but every time i go to new york city i go to the museum of sex because it's so funny like it was a tradition with me and my friends like it was like um it was like a uh like a girl's uh like a girl's trip but like every time we're in new york we had to go there because it's so funny and but like so i was like i had to go there because it's humor of like a preteen of a pre pre-blessed boy like i of a of like a pre-teen teenager boy so um um and so like so i had to go i was so disappointed they downsized they they took away all the fun stuff of like what what it was about because there used to be like um there used to be like a floor dedicated to like crazy ass like um stuff that
animals would do like freaky fucking animals and then they would have like giant fucking tape sculptures of like deer a deer threesome and shit like that it was so fucking wild and I always thought it was so funny and but they took all that away and i i think kovat got them i i can't show any of the photos i took by the way because i would get i would actually get bad like so they they actually was gone it was actually gone and then um i still actually still have the photos from my visit to to that museum i still have that photo um of like the crazy ass like animal floor because it was fucking crazy uh it's fucking crazy because i and it was so long ago i still have that photo have those photos um anyway anyway it was like i felt so sad because like it became an actual museum museum Like it was like super educational So like two of the galleries was talking about like Like cults,
you know Like crazy sex cults So like but it was not funny crazy sex cults It was educational So it was like they had like documentaries and videos playing about like that Like the crazy sex cult but it wasn't like a funny documentary It was like very educational and they would have like,
you know, like photos of like, you know, the hippies, you know, the hippie groups and stuff like that.
And like here are some of the clothes they wore.
And I was like, bro, boo!
I was like, clothes they wore?
What is this?
So, um, so they were actually like teaching stuff.
Um, so I got, it was so fucking, okay.
um they and then their newest exhibit uh was about was about carnivals and like how fucking wild carnivals were but i didn't come here exactly i didn't come here to learn i think i gave you the fucking i thought it would be fun i thought it would be funny like how it was back then but like they down they cut the exhibit in half uh local teenager to find sex is no longer funny all right thank you the super chat thank you thank you okay so they had like carnival games and stuff and um and like there's like it's like oh my god okay so it was fucking wild so they had a tunnel of love so i was like what the fuck is the tunnel of love and like oh it's five dollars And I was like,
okay.
And they're like, oh, yeah.
They're like, it's $5.
And it's a 4D experience.
And I'm like, okay.
Because this is the one time you have to pay for extra for it.
So I was like, okay.
And she was like, yeah, it's an orgy.
And I was like, what?
And then, so then I was like, okay, I gotta see what this is.
Like, how do you make this up for it?
It was not.
By the way, it was.
was not.
It was an abstract film.
It was a fucking abstract, guys.
It was an abstract film, where, like, you know how, like, those crazy art films where you don't know what the fuck is going?
That's basically it.
You don't know what the fuck is going on.
I was just like, who am I watching?
But the 4D part was crazy.
Yeah, it's an art film.
It was literally an art film where like it felt like I was like it felt like I was on acid or some shit I felt clickbait I felt like I got clickbaited um by the way I was the only one sitting there too so it was so awkward so there was one moment where they showed a hole you know like it wasn't like you know like porn it was like it was just a hole like you know like just like it was artistic it was So and then it started like raining in that hole and then I was like,
wow, it's so wet And then water blew in my face the moment I said that out loud.
I was like, damn, that's a wet hole And then I got water blown in my face for the 4D effect as you go into the I was just like, oh my god, that's crazy oh my god and then when you're sitting on a chair because it's the 4d it's the 4d effect like it starts hitting you in the chair starts hitting you in the back as if you're getting fucking backshot And I'm like,
oh, no, no
No It's just like like the chair just starts hitting like like fucking hitting you in the back and I'm like, oh my god
Anyway, that was the worst five dollars I spent I was the worst I was like, let me off of this crazy ride.
Like, that's awful.
It was, anyway, I did not consent to that.
Um, what an experience.
So, um, the worst $5 I spent.
Um, it was, I was literally watching a French avant-garde abstract art film.
Like, you can't, like, I don't, one time, oh, it wasn't one part.
There was like this man with a hole in his chest and then a woman crawled out of a naked woman crawled out of his fucking chest And I'm like what the fuck this is not sexy.
I I am not feeling like Sexy at all From this entire film.
Yeah, I was just like holy shit.
What the fuck like What does that even mean?
I know I was like what the fuck?
is and at one point it was just metal gates and they're all like the like men were just like like gyrating against this metal gates and stuff like what am i watching what am i just
gyrating against the metal gates and everything i'm like oh my god what the fuck is this this too i thought it was a fun i thought it would be fun like back then like younger dokey when she had a girl's trip at the when she had her girl's trip in new york city with her friends and we're like he he the sex museum it was not it was not fun it they changed it where this new update fucking sucks solid thank you the super chat thank you thank you and then okay the carnival games oh my god okay so there was one where um you know like those things where you roll like a ball into these holes and then like a horse there's like a horse race or whatever um and you have to get to the others like you know whoever wins um gets a prize so you're competing against other guests and stuff so all these all these games were free by the way um except for the tunnel of love fuck that uh fuck that last five dollars um and the prize i shit you not the prize was a stress ball shaped like a fucking vagina i was
like oh my god and they're like whoever wins gets the stress gets the stress a jean stress ball and i was just like oh my god i won by the way i i have and it's chrome by the way the color is chrome i won i not wasn't trying to i just thought it was a free game it was a free game i have and by the way it's also chrome colored too so I can't.
I can't show it.
I get bad.
I actually can't show.
No, there's no way you can censor it.
There's no way you can, that's the worst part.
There's no way you can censor this.
That's the worst part, guys.
I won, but I somehow lost.
I do not.
You sure it was not a toy that you, super chat thank you thank you look I just I didn't mean to win they were they just they were just so bad I just wanted to play the game no funny game okay and then I play this other game where okay I don't know how to explain this game very okay I can but also I'm very embarrassed to your crystal minion robin thank you for the super chat thank you thank you okay i don't know how to explain this i know how to explain it but i'm actually very embarrassed but like it was this game i saw other people i saw two girls were playing it i was like what the fuck is going i can't even show a picture of this game because her the boobs are out but um basically it was like make the siren sing and then i was like what and then i you stick your head into this boot like hole and then you're supposed to make your sing
so so i was like wait they have prizes like they have prizes and okay anyway let's just move on to the I won a prize and um and it was literally CBD I it was called love potion gaze deeply into your lover's eyes as you drink this potion and then I looked at the ingredients and it says this is a CBD product and I was like what the fuck I I threw it away because I don't do that.
I don't know because they're like, you have to, you apparently has to be consumed within 24 hours.
And I was like, I'm not fucking with this.
I'm throwing this away.
I threw it away because I was like, I'm not fucking with this.
I am not.
I don't, I don't do CBD too.
So I was like, I'm not fucking, I'm not gonna fucking do this my first time.
myself in new york city i i don't want to do this to do b too i don't know what i'm gonna i want to do this to do b as well so i was like holy shit
bro it's not i took a picture of it because i was like what the fuck i took a picture of the love potion with um but this is what it looked like on the back it says this was this cvd product and i was like oh my god this was this is the prize i won this was the love potion so i won that um i didn't do anything with it but i won it there he's companion nature turns against her at least we know it's The siren scene.
It wasn't...
Okay, you were turning the wheel.
It's literally a wheel inside it.
You were just turning it.
If you guys want to know, it wasn't that freaky.
The way it was presented was so fucking freaky.
But it was a free game.
And I was like, I paid $30.
Okay, the tickets were like $30 plus dollars.
And I was like, I paid $30 plus dollars to be in this museum.
I'm fucking playing these games because it's free.
Like it comes with my ticket.
it yeah yeah
no i got robbed i was so sad it's not the same it felt they fell off they they fell off also um we did go to a normal museum me and dubie went to a normal museum and it was the um it was like it was spy it's called spy scape or whatever basically it's a museum about spies and it was so cool because it talks about like um all the like spies around the world in history and they actually had like um the prop like actual like uh um what's the word uh artifacts from like back then like the small spies stuff and like spy gadgets like actual real ass spy gadgets and and yeah i took her to a fun museum that i didn't take her to the other one okay i went there by myself um yeah like not even replicas it's like actual like from during that era um so yeah they even have like the cars the clothes and um um like the gadgets and stuff and they're little like spy games and stuff so like there's like lie detectors like how to tell someone's lying and then there was like the laser like you can like
there's like a laser game where you have to try and push all these buttons without getting getting hit by the lasers it was so fucking cool i wish i took photos of it but i didn't but it was such a fucking it was such a cool museum and wait i want to see what photos did i take any photos from that um but um let me see um oh i saw okay i had to take a picture of that i thought it was so funny I took a picture of one of the exhibits because I thought it was so silly.
They even have like, they have like a security room too where you have to like try and see how good you are at monitoring people.
So it's an entire room and then around the room there were monitors, security cameras everywhere and monitors and stuff.
And then it's like a little game.
You're like on a phone and it's a little game you play where they're like, oh, which camera shows...
Which camera shows two men talking to each other at the dining table?
And you have to look around the camera and be like, oh, camera 33 or camera.
So it tests your surveillance skills.
Because that's what they do when you're surveilling.
They are able to monitor everything at once.
So they would be like, oh, which camera shows a guy juggling?
And then you're like, oh, we have to look around the room.
Like, oh, where is that camera?
So they're playing Five Nights at Freddy's.
Yeah, basically that, but with, like, it was a lot harder.
It was a lot harder than the actual game.
Um, let me take it fine then.
I took picture here.
Just saved it.
Where is it?
La la la.
I am Nord.
Oh, yeah, this one.
I wanted to show you guys this because I thought it was funny.
Um, basically, this is a real gear explosive rat.
I.
I saw this.
I was like, oh my god, explosive rat.
What?
It was a real spy gear.
It made a rat fucking explode.
That's hardcore.
I had to take a picture of that.
Also, like, there was like a personality.
It was so funny.
Okay.
There was a personality test.
And like an IQ.
Okay, so like in the ticket, there's like several boosts where you have to answer these questions.
So it's not just personality.
It's like personality, IQ, and I don't remember the other one.
And like a risk test.
Risk.
So when I got to the IQ test, I did two questions and then I gave up and just do like rat.
I just randomly answered.
Because I gave up.
I was like, I'm not thinking today.
And then do it be.
She was actually taking it seriously.
And answering them.
Like with her brain.
You know.
And I think she got like.
I think she got like.
9 out of 16.
And me out of pure random luck.
Got 6 out of.
I think it was.
No.
It was.
I think.
Yeah.
I got 6 out of 16.
Of me just doing.
Boop, boop, boop.
Boop.
like you know me not even like actually I was like I was like I was like my fucking thinking right now because they're like oh math questions and like pattern recognition questions like which one which would be the next shape in this pattern I'm like fuck this and then what was fucking hilarious was she got she got agent handler you know the one that handles the agents and like manages them he wishes pretty good but i got i got the head leader of of intelligence agency like literally the ceo slash uh head director of the spy agency with my
I don't know, I mean, I don't know, apparently I'm just, I'm just that good.
I did not, I'm the spot master.
Yeah, we are both, how does that make sense?
That's impressive and concerning.
so I got that that was fucking hilarious um but yeah no it was it was super cool this museum was actually like I said I did a lot of like things where I'm experiencing stuff like you know for the first time and just like going to museums and stuff I went through a lot of museum like the museum ice cream I got a lot of ice cream at the museum ice cream is so good um um museum ice cream the spot also I don't know if you guys ever seen those Twitter videos of like people were like pressing like you know you guys seen these Twitter videos where like people press a button There's like lights on the floor chasing you and you have to go to the next button and stuff like that You know that that's from this museum.
They had a section.
There's another section where it's called spy games And it's like a bunch of like light centered like okay, wait, I'll show you guys the video.
I've seen it It went viral on Twitter and I'll see um It went viral on Twitter and I've always wanted to play those games Um Uh Uh, but but I've always wanted to play it.
So I was like, oh my god, this is the place.
Yeah, with the boxes and lights.
Yeah, so wait.
Spy games.
I'm trying to say I can find a video for you guys.
Because it's so fun.
It's actually, it was so fun.
Like, I think it's, I'm trying to find the one with the Hazard one.
The really famous one where people were like running around.
Running around and pushing buttons and stuff.
Um, I'm trying to find it.
It was like, oh my god.
I want to find that exact video.
Hazard.
It was like called Hazard.
I think it was like Hazard something.
Hazard play?
I think.
Is that it?
How it works.
I'll just show you guys.
I'll just show you the normal video.
The social experience.
It's basically...
Okay, moving...
Okay, moving hazard.
I was so sad.
I wanted to play moving hazard because that was the one that's on Twitter.
Um, that was a spy.
That was the one I saw that was went viral on Twitter.
But like, literally they didn't have it today.
I think it was like that day.
I think it was closed down or something.
They said I can grab a TikTok.
Maybe I'll grab a TikTok.
Um...
Oh, this...
sure, yes, it's this one.
It's so cool.
So, we did this, like, me and Duby, and it was so fun.
Because, like, oh, my god, like, there was one we saw.
We saw two people doing this climbing thing and we're like, oh, that doesn't look so hard.
we're like, we're watching them.
They're doing this climbing game where you have to, like, climb um climb around i was like that looks so easy like that looks so it was not easy at all it was because they were like freezing through they were looping around and everything like we can't do that we could not we did not do it like oh my god how did they do this how did they climb around so easily yeah they were like they got like top 30 or some shit on the leader but I'm like that's easy we can do that it was not it was it was not it was surprisingly very difficult to climb but that was so fucking fun it was actually so yeah those people they know what they're doing they definitely go outside these guys definitely go outside we we were not okay um um but i didn't that was like one of the most fun experiences um definitely um um when we were like just like uh playing the spy games i i like that one um if you guys ever are new york city you should try that one try that game out it's honestly really fun um yeah professional
grass touchers yeah that's what we are uh under the teeth thank you for the raid thank you thank you i hope you had a great stream i'm trying to see what else i can show you guys uh i'm looking through all my photos right now oh man i'm just talking about my new york trip um i'm gonna show you guys all the food i took so much photos of food i don't know which one i shown already though i show any oh yeah i show deconstructed the deconstructed French rabbit it was crazy I can't it was I mean it was experience I was like I don't think I don't think that restaurant's gonna survive I that's I'm sorry like we were like um like I like I said we as if like dubie was dubie just said no dubie did not want to come with me to the deconstructed ramen place.
Which is understandable.
When I was there, I was the only one there.
No one else came into the restaurant.
She knew better.
No one else came into the, it was just me.
And I was just like, oh.
Also, here's more picture of food.
Wait a sec.
My food.
I edited a little bit oh it didn't save sad i thought i edited it i need to edit it again because it didn't save sad but i don't know oh it's because i need to save it save
all right okay here you go look at this this yet look at this oh my god that's too big
bam look at that that was good though it was like um what is it called i don't remember what these are called benny's or some oh yeah i forgot to show you guys the pizza we got all right pizza time let me make sure there's no reflections eggs benedic yeah is that what column eggs benedict oh yeah but this is the pizza we got from pizza time it was so good it was actually a really good pizza look at that yum yum yum it was so good too oh my god like if you guys can get to go joe's i mean as seen in spider-man remember it was seen in spider-man guys this is literally the pizza time pizza time why is it like that it's pizza time
Don't you dare say bad about pizza time It's up Spider-Man pizza Pizza time I'm gonna use the bathroom real quick I'll be back guys
Uh hey rice rose Zechra, Nepper, Stuff, Kami, J-L, 4 Nexi and Medi Thank you for the super chat Thank you uh broku more fun stay in the super chat thank you thank you looking back well so i want to talk oh my god i was there's so many cool cosplay i'll show you i'll show you guys this cosplay i thought it was so funny um because i was like what a crossover if you guys know the cosplay please feel free to let um to let me know um also oh my god i got into like this so i didn't want to talk about.
I didn't want to like put more attention on it on Twitter.
It was so fucking weird.
But like um so I didn't take a lot of the cosplay photos um because I asked like a staff to help me take photos of it um just because I got worried about doxing and stuff.
So obviously like they didn't tell me like Twitter handles and stuff like that.
So it was so weird because like one person got so angry that I didn't get I didn't credit the cosplayer um and like I waited 12 hours to at that time and like i've like shown cosplays before and like other i've seen other people show cosplays before um you know without like it's just like oh look at this cool thing also like i was also on vacation slash on a business trip so like i wasn't checking twitter that much but also when i posted that yeah there was this it was weird it's fucking weird because like um like you know i'm really busy i was like trying to enjoy my vacation so i wasn't looking at replies but it was crazy because the one thing they were really mad about is that they were like why did you wait 12 hours to credit and then like this one guy that was crashing out and then he made that reply at two in the morning it's so no and no not even two in them yeah so i woke up at six in the like five and like i woke up at five in the morning and i this and then I was just like
and then I put the credit because I saw that oh the cosplayer like said was like this is me and then so then I posted a credit because I woke up so I was like I was sleeping like I was just like in my head I was just like bro I'm not terminally online 24 I'm on a vacation technically like first it was a business trip but then it turned into a vacation I was like bro i was sleeping like i'm so confused like um so like i was just like bro what the fuck it's five in the morning too by the way by the way it's like it's good that i woke up early enough to put the credit also like when i posted that photo it was like 6 p.m for me it was 6 p.m but i had the the comedy club at 11 30 so i took a nap and then obviously i wasn't checking my twitter because um you know i was napping after i posted a photo and then you know i took a picture of the comedy seller and then they locked my phone up for another two out like i woke up from my nap and then i went to the comedy club that was at 11 30 i went
to 11 and then and then so so i got you know made us steal our phones so and then it was two in the morning and then i went home and went back to the hotel and i slept like you see the timeline so i was just like i it wasn't on purpose that like all that happened i was literally enjoying my vacation and and then and then yeah no they make you steal your phone at the comedy club because i don't want you to record in case they say some incredibly edgy jokes and they don't want to get canceled,
like the comedians.
So, yeah, and I felt so weird.
And they were like, why didn't you edit the tweet to fit?
And I was like, bro, I know you don't have Twitter blue because you can only edit a tweet within the first 30 minutes.
So I was just like, why are you?
I was like, why, what?
They're like, and then the cosplayer also got mad because I didn't edit the tweet to include her.
But I was like, I was like, like I'm sorry it's been 30 minutes I can delete the tweet I feel like you'd be mad if I delete the tweet because then it loses all the engagement so I was just like I can't win I was just like I can't win in this scenario like so I was just like I'm sorry I'm not sorry I did my best yeah it's a loose loose situation that's why i just like ignored it after that i like i was just letting them argue to themselves it was just and i continue tweeting about my vacation yeah it's just so awkward i like muted the tweet because i was like i can't win in this situation just gonna keep tweeting about my my time in new york city like yeah like people just want to be angry so at that What else am I going to do?
like, it ain't that deep, guys.
I was literally...
When all of this was happening, I was sleeping majority of the time.
Like, there was so...
The thing is, there was a lot of cosplay photos, too.
Um, that was taken.
So, uh...
Um, so it was like...
Um, so it was like, I didn't know, because like um also i've like posted i like seen like people you know post cosplays all the time and i didn't realize like at that time i didn't realize there's etiquette to uh make sure you have their twitter handles and everything because uh um so like so like i didn't realize now i know now i know because like you know i asked staff and be like oh hey can you get me the photos apparently the staff was told twit some twitter hands but like i guess like they forgot to tell me And at that time,
I didn't know.
So, like, now I do.
So, like, if I ever tweet about, like, cosplay photos.
So I don't have Twitter handles for these photos.
But I thought they were so cool.
But if you guys do know the cosplayers, just please.
Feel free to drop them down.
But I thought it...
Okay, look at this.
So I thought this was crazy.
This was, like, crossover.
Like, look at this cosplay.
Look at this.
This shit is cool.
Like, Wukon with Doctor Doom.
It was so...
They were, like, together.
They were, like, it was such a weird-ass combo.
Wukon with Doctor Doom.
Like, it was sick, though.
That cosplay was fucking sick.
Just funny.
The crossover we need.
Yeah, I was like, bro, that's insane.
And then a random baby in the background.
Now, I know they both go so hard.
It's cosplay.
And then there were hell divers.
Oh, my God.
That's so cool.
I saw some hell diver cosplays.
Look at this.
They're just chilling.
But, okay, they have their heads.
By the way, they didn't get to get, look at this though.
Oh my god.
Look at, oh my god.
I thought, like, the hell, there were so many hell diver cosplays.
They were, like, everywhere.
I saw so many hell divers for democracy.
Um, oh my god, this one was cute.
Okay, this one was badass.
I like this one.
Look at this one.
This one was fucking cool.
Like, the zombie captain of, I went to the, I went to the Marvel meetup and also the Marvel rival.
meetup to look at the cosplay um they were all so good like oh my i thought this one was insane the zombie captain america with the um oh they're doing cute right here uh with the with the regular captain america uh yeah is zombie yeah the zombie captain there was a there was a zombie Marvel meetup.
I was like, and surprisingly, there were so many cosplays.
I guess it's based off of the zombie show, the zombie cartoon that just came out on Disney Plus.
But I was so surprised there were a lot of cosplayers just dedicated to Marvel zombies.
Like, there was literally a meetup just for the zombies.
I didn't wait to look at it because I didn't want to, you know, I wanted to look at the other stuff at the convention like Duby and I.
Oh yeah, also Duby um she i found out that um she is obsessed with the winter soldier but it was so funny because we were talking about we were having our like ex-fujo moments like um because we were talking about our history of being ex-fujo's because we're both ex-fujo's and she's telling me that she learned about winter soldier by just reading fat bits of the winter she pieced together like winter soldier history and lore by just reading the fan fictions of winter soldier and I thought it was so because I was telling her how I used to did that too because I told you guys um I pieced together one piece like the lore of one piece and what the characters are from reading the fanfics of one piece of a one piece pairing and but because I didn't even know what they did.
I didn't know what they did.
I didn't know what their history or anything, but I really like the two characters.
And then I would read fanfics about those two characters and then piece together their character and like the lore and everything from just reading the fanfics.
And then Duby was like, oh, that's just like me with Winter Soldier.
And so like, that's how that's how I learned it.
But but yeah, she's like really into I think I heard her talking about Um, she's really into Winter Soldier right now.
I even, like, I helped her take photos of, like, all the Bucky's I saw at, uh, uh, all the Bucky's I saw and took photos for her.
Uh, hear me out.
So I thought, I thought that was, I thought that was really funny.
Um, uh, Gina, thank you for the five.
Thank you.
No, no.
We're both ex-Fujos, guys.
What else?
I want to show you.
I mean, I took a lot of photos, but I don't know which one I want.
Oh, wait, God, here.
I got...
Wait, I got to make sure there's no reflection.
I always have to, like, be sure.
Because I took the photos without, like, you know.
Checking things fully.
I'll check it later.
Today is later.
Right now is later.
Oh, there's so many photos.
I don't know which.
Oh my god, I took a photo with Beyonce.
You guys want to see that?
Guys, I took a photo with Beyonce.
Yes.
Let me see.
Okay.
Where is Beyonce?
Where is the queen?
Look at this, guys.
It's me and Beyonce.
I'm in the perfect position.
Oh, whip Beyonce.
There's a photo.
I do have a photo where it's from the bottom.
bottom-up perspective, but I don't think that's safe.
I mean, it is safe, but then I don't want you guys to judge me.
I don't, it is safe, but I just, I don't know.
I just, I feel a little embarrassed.
I feel a little embarrassed with that camera.
I thought it would be funny, but then I looked at the photo and I was like, oh, I look like a creep.
I, I was like, oh, I look like a creep.
Maybe I shouldn't.
Maybe I also look.
Oh my god, I got a photo with Nicholas Cage No shame Look at that The bees, not the bees
Oh also Oh my gosh, I'm gonna show you guys some food too I found a cool Ice cream Taiyaki place Before I left It was so good I was like, yum, yum, yum, yum, yum Let me show you guys.
And I added the cotton candy sprinkles because I'm a child.
Tiki.
Look at that.
It's a Tayaki ice cream.
How much to embarrass yourself by posting it.
Next, he thank you for the super chat.
No, it's okay.
I'm, it's okay.
I've already embarrassed myself enough with the museum stories.
Like, classic toky, the cake connoisseur.
Hey, guys.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Yeah.
I said, guys, I already, I already, have I not.
embarrassed myself enough with the story with the museum story have I not is that not oh my god okay wait I guys I gotta show this photo I'm mr.
frog look at me hello I'm so sad mr.
frog is gone forever story but look I'm the new miss hello I'm mr.
frog I but but I won't go like i won't go like super cancelable on on the jimmy fallon show all right hello i'm toky bird hi tonight's i'm tonight's special guest what do you mean oh spoiler they ended his character arc oh my god oh they they had the adult swim booth at the comic con there were so many many things at comic con i honestly it's so hard to like uh talk about everything because there was just a lot of stuff to do at comic con um there's just like so many crazy booths oh we oh my god there was this gotcha booth and i swear to fucking god there was a brain rot song that was like gotcha pond gotcha pot and like we would we're doing uh uh dubia now we're doing gotcha and stuff at the gotcha pond booth and like it was literally on repeat it's like gotcha pond gotcha pond gotcha gotcha gotcha literally for it the entire time it was just one song and one song with two lyrics and it's gotcha pond gotcha pond gotcha gotcha gotcha and i was going crazy i it was it was so i just like
imagine you're at the employee working at that gotcha pond machine like gotcha pond booth That's all you fucking hear for like seven plus hours.
Like I don't, I don't understand.
They're so brave.
They're so fucking brave.
Oh, I didn't take any pictures of the gotcha I won.
I got, but I got the Kalulu.
I was so happy because I got, they would have like Kelolo gotcha and I got the one I wanted.
I got the Kalulu one.
It was like a baby Kalulu and he was just sleeping.
I was so happy.
I also got like a little, I got a little, I'll show it later, maybe in the next stream because I don't want to take pictures right now.
I'm a little lazy.
I don't want to take pictures right now.
But I'll show more pictures of the stuff I got.
I also got pins of like I think they're exclusive pins for playing the demos of Resident Evil and Onimusha.
So they gifted us these pins and stuff.
There's a lot.
Let's see.
Looking at what else I did.
I wrote like a lot a little a small little log but i think i talked about everything uh yeah exclusive swag and everything oh my god during the french ramen place i saw two girls making tiktok videos of like the moonbeam side moonbeam they look so happy in life but it was so cringe i literally was like while i was waiting at the french ramen place like i saw two girls just like making actual They look so happy.
They're so oblivious to the real world.
I was just like, man, they don't know how... They look so happy.
They were living their best life right now.
Oh, they had a Dr. Eggman cosplay at comic.
I'm so sad I didn't take a picture of it.
It was so good.
The doctor... It's like the... It was like the Jim Carrey Dr. Eggman.
He looked just like, he looked just like the movie The Jim Carrey, Dr. Eggman, too It looked just like him And I wish I took a photo Instead I took a little creep shot So I'm not going to show it
I took It was like a creep shot of him With his kids And I was like I'm not going to show it Because I was like oh my god I gotta say so cool I can't show it What do you mean?
Why are you like this?
I can't.
Guys, I can't.
Also, also, I realized, you know how like I tweeted that cosplay photo and it went out of my circle?
Because everyone says that in Marvel Rivals and it went out of my circle.
So I can't say that anymore because I was like, no, it's supposed to be supposed to have Marvel Rivals me.
swear it's supposed to be a marble rivals meme everyone it's crazy because it's like everyone says it in marble rivals so it's like so it's just like i didn't realize it would go out of my circle it would karma thank you for the super chat thank you thank you um i heard nicholas cage and joking the same sentence from a headphone while making dinner.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Yeah.
I told you.
I'm a changed person now.
I need to get rid of the mold first before I can say.
Oh, yeah.
I was asking Duby if she wanted to do.
I thought it was a Marvel Rivals meme because it was.
I thought it was a Marvel Rivals.
I learned at that day.
At that day, I learned.
I keep learning it, too, because I was like, yeah, I keep relearning it.
This time, I learned, for real, that day that it's not just the Marvel Rivals meme anymore.
Anyway, I wanted to do a, in a skate room, because there was a really cool skate room in New York, but, like, Duby was, like, not into it, because another fun fact from Duby.
She's like, yeah, I don't really want to do an escape room because I read that one time Someone got like a group got trapped in the escape room and there was a fire and then they died in that escape room Because they couldn't escape and I was like, I was like in New York and she was like,
no in Australia And I was like, oh shit, I guess they didn't escape the escape escape room um so so we didn't do it we didn't do the escape room uh I don't know what's going on in Australia that I was like well I was like to be fair it is in Australia so like shit always happens there but yeah if you don't if you don't escape the escape room you fucking die like I was like holy fuck um um but but yeah no that's why that's why we didn't do the escape room because because like she was scared that we could wouldn't escape and then there would be a fire and then we die in the escape room also i want to talk about also spoiler because i really want to talk about that new the new also like i feel like that new pokemon game has not been hyped that much as i thought it'd be um because i feel like no one's other than the fucking mega evolution of star me that's fucking that is like oh i didn't know how what to like i didn't know what to like say uh when i saw like literally i was speechless
when i first saw the fucking um the fucking running out of like running animation on star me um so spoiler alert uh for those who um didn't see it on twitter this is what i'm talking about this is so fucking like he just starts running like bro bro just he's just running i don't know what else to say he's just i was like is this real and i realized oh the new pokemon game also fucking hilarious i like how someone made a comparison they're like game freak is just yonder a dub but with an insane Apparently,
the map for the, the map for the, like the world, the main, the big world, I guess, the city in the new Pokemon game, it's literally one model.
It's the entire model of that city.
It's one model.
Yeah.
It's not even like separate models in like one area.
It's one giant.
ass model like it's crazy so that's why people were like oh why is the why is like the building so fucking flat because it's one model like it's not it's literally just one giant like that's crazy it's that's actually it's insane like i i saw that and i'm like there's no fucking way Like,
there's no fucking way.
It's just, it's just, I can't even, like, defend it.
That's actually insane to think about.
Yeah.
I, yeah.
So, I thought that was really, really funny.
I, um, that seems hard.
I don't know.
I don't, like, I don't know how to feel.
feel like I don't I don't even know if it's easier at that point to model an entire city uh like is that even easier like I don't know I like I just like the craziest shit you can do just like make an entire city but it's just one one giant ass model I I don't know I I know definitely not
yeah if you want to edit the building you have to edit the entire model i know that's like wow and i really wanted to talk about i wanted to talk about the star me shit and then because like honestly that's peak that's peak pokemon right there like i think that has to be my favorite newest pokemon design that they've ever done and they just gave him legs but it's so good and he's he sent a message and that message was like the was so clear like it's just it's just like keep he made an impression on all of us and it's memorable all the other ones i saw the other ones and i was like it's not as memorable as fucking uh the running star me the star like he looks like a goddamn titan running at you like he just it's just he sent a message and it was it was loud and clear like it was so memorable um honestly the best mega evolution they've ever done um um oh my god I've been talking for four hours I miss streaming with you guys chat I really didn't miss streaming um it was a nice vacation um
I feel a lot refreshed now um I mean it was a business trip turned into a vacation huge shout out to Capcom again for inviting me um to Comic-Con and checking everything out.
I really wanted to go to the panels but I felt like I don't know I didn't I felt like it felt like I would like lose a lot of my time checking out the panels too.
I was going to try one of the panels because I wanted to check out the adventure time the Fiona um and cake panel um but I felt like I felt like I would just be too much of it.
I would have to wait in line way and like and then like doesn't even mean guarantee i'd get seats because people would be camping that fucking uh so uh i didn't do any in the panels but i mean i even only had time to leave half of comic-con too um so uh oh yeah the new onimusha game it's basically the the fighting wise felt like i would say like i never played securo but it felt like it felt souls like the fighting because the parry is a lot easier obviously because like the older games were a long time ago but um the current like like the the the fighting mechanic felt like there's like blocking and parries and stuff like that and it felt like um it felt very soul's leg yeah so um so like that's how I felt like when I was playing the game um I don't never played Sekiro but I assume that's how Sekiro is supposed to feel like I I never played it but I assume because It felt like it felt very soul's like with a dot.
There's like dodging like the dodging mechanic There's a dodging there's like parry and there's block too.
So um, but anyway Um, it's good to be back tomorrow.
Maybe I'll play silk song.
I'm not gonna do a schedule for it This week just because there's only a couple of days left of this week.
Um, but maybe tomorrow I'll do silk song.
Um, but Saturday I do have a sponsored pub g. Um, I think it's called blind spot I think that's the new pub g game i got guys how do i get rid of guys do i do i do i pour water in the bowl first before i start scraping the mold out can i put the mold in the sink or is that bad guys do i scrape it in a trash bag or i can't i can't throw it away that's the thing because i do i rinse it do i rinse it while scrape it no the thing is i have to give it back to the clean like the the chef i can't throw it away or they'll charge me like a lot uh they actually would charge me a lot if i um if i if i if i don't return everything so i rather just clean it um hot water and scrape it in a trash bag okay um and then i'll put and then i'll put it in the dishwasher again after it uh scrape it and Then wash it.
Um, don't add water.
To the trash and then wash it.
Okay, wait.
Hot water, then scrape it.
Okay.
I'll put a face mask on.
I don't have any other mask and I'll use gloves.
Okay.
I'll put it.
Uh, I don't have bleach.
I don't have bleach.
I'll tell them about that and they can bleach it.
I'll put it in a dishwasher.
I have a dishwasher that does disinfectant.
So it'll, like, be, like, super hot.
stuff so i'll scrape it out then i'll uh rinse it and then i'll put it in the dishwasher and then it'll be like 100 plus degrees um and yeah um good enough okay after i scrape i don't want to look at it right okay so i gotta deal with it's okay it's only one of the bullets that had everything else is fine that freaked me out it was literally jump scare because i forgot to like cap like I forgot to like push down the cover before I left um so um it was literally like mold jump scare I was freaked out because the bowl was just mold and I was like oh god uh so I gotta figure yeah uh so it was just one bowl so I'll wear the mask yeah um so what we learned I learned that I should have I should have fixed that before I went out but I was really late for my plane so it was it was bad um anyway hey guys it's good to be back i hope you guys had a great time uh listening to my stories and hanging out with me today um i can't believe four hours passed by so fast like actually i felt like it was
um you know i it felt like i didn't it doesn't feel like i've been talking for this long but it was definitely a fun time yapping with all of you guys I mean, I'm pretty sure I had so much photos.
I could have shared more, but maybe I'll show more at another time.
Anyway, guys, as always, everybody, stay hydrated, posture check.
Get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you stay up from me, head to bed, guys, you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye, guys.
Bye.
Bonus ending, bonus ending.
Most likely, the birthday concert, I finally got everything.
it most likely will be uploaded at the end of the week sunday or maybe Sunday or maybe like next week just letting guys know I finally got the director's cut of it I think I'm not sure if that was the final one because they were like is this okay I was like yeah but I'm not sure if it's the final one but most likely if it is most likely uploaded on Sunday anyway bye for real bye-bye